a Manhattan Grand Jury has voted to
indict Donald Trump we don't have the
full details yet but there it is ladies
and gentlemen all of these conservative
but anti-trump people who kept saying
Trump was grifting and lying he was
never going to be indicted oh they have
back on their face because Donald
Trump's been indicted and you had many
on the left liberals who were saying he
was going to be indicted they were
excited for it and your Trump supporter
saying this is an egregious violation of
social or political Norms but uh here we
go the NYPD has ordered a full
mobilization all officers are ordered to
wear their uniforms and get ready for
potential unrest and uh there's a lot to
break down in that story alone so oh boy
do we have a lot to go through before we
get started we've got a few things to
shout out it's the last day for us for
our new song Bright Eyes
so go to trashhouserecords.com purchase
the song Bright Eyes for whatever you
want this is the last day so if
everybody buys a song hopefully we can
smash onto billboard for the fourth time
getting four of four songs on Billboard
so again trash House Records we also
have launched cast Brew Coffee yeah
we're uh we're sponsoring ourselves we
launched our own coffee brand Roberto Jr
is the mascot go to castbrew.com
pre-order yours today they just entered
production and they will ship by May 5th
we have two signature Blends rise with
Roberto Jr you all know Roberto Jr he's
our rooster and Appalachian nights
Roberto Junior's blend is a light roast
Appalachian nights of course a dark
roast and then we have we have a
Colombian and a French roast they come
in ground or whole bean we are our own
sponsors now so we can't get canceled if
you want to support our endeavors go to
castbrew.com and of course go to
timcast.com become a member because
tonight we're gonna have a members only
uncensored show after the main show
which I'm sure is going to be fun either
way so uh we will also have Collins if
you become a member you can join our
Discord server where you can submit
questions and actually call into the
uncensored after show and have your
questions answered we do that Monday
through Thursday so it will be a lot of
fun and it's going to be especially a
lot of fun because today we are joined
by the Omni liberal himself destiny
hey what's up trying really hard to
follow the rules right now okay yeah all
right uh do you want to just tell people
who you are what do you do you've been
on the show before uh yeah my name is uh
Destiny and realethica by Stephen
Bunnell you can find me at youtube.com
Destiny and I debate people from a
center love Progressive position and
that's what I've been doing for about
the past six or seven years and then
before that I would say Starcraft 2
semi-professional gamer wow who are you
Zerg protoss Taryn Zerg obviously
I I will say this
um there's very few people we associate
with the left who come who are willing
to come on the show most people we
encounter we politely offer we'll say
like hey we'll fly you out we really
have a conversation I think they're all
liars but what happened to Lance
he's coming is he yeah yeah absolutely
surfs oh my goodness absolutely
scheduled him to come on and he said
hell yeah and I was like cool like I'm
totally down to have anybody who's in
the political conversation come on and
talk about these ideas but I got to be
honest I think a lot of them are just
lying and I don't I do not count you as
one of them I think you actually are
intelligent you have a lot of good
points and I think you just have
different opinions so I think we'll have
a good conversation so thanks for coming
man yeah thanks for having me we also
have Sean from uncensored America hi how
you doing who are you and what do you do
uh give this guy a lot of trouble that's
what I do uh my name is Sean samanko I
found the Free Speech organization on
Central America and we basically host uh
speaking events on college campuses with
anybody that's censored canceled or
anything in between honestly and we're
gonna have a debate with Stephen and
Milo coming up on Christian nationalism
at the University of Tennessee it's
going to be in a couple weeks so that's
cool if you want tickets go to
unscentedamerica.us and we'll have some
for that and also Laura Loomer is going
to be speaking at University of South
Carolina right on right on awesome man I
mean awesome you hit me up at Ian
Crossland anywhere on the internet good
to see you guys let's move we also have
surge over here yo I am search.com
pleasure Destiny it's nice to see you in
real life uh let's do this all right
before we uh before we go much further
because Sean okay we're gonna bring this
up
festival.minds.com I believe you and I
are both doing an event there in a few
weeks yeah April 15th yeah in Austin if
you guys want tickets for that they're
still selling tickets so yes we're we're
doing a live Tim cast IRL that Friday
and that sold out but the minds event is
the second day at the same location the
Vulcan and you guys are going to be
there Ian I'll be there too I'll be
speaking that day yeah right on all
right let's jump into this big breaking
news story ladies and gentlemen breaking
Manhattan grand jury votes to indict
Donald Trump trump will be the first
former president to be indicted the
grand jury's vote regards an alleged
settlement made with adult film actress
Stormy Daniels during the former
president's 2016 campaign according to
five people with knowledge of the matter
per the New York Times Trump and Dale's
allegedly had a actual encounter in 2006
according to the claim Trump is the
first former president to face criminal
charges after office while the specific
charges are currently unknown an
indictment is expected to be announced
as Trump will be asked to surrender and
face arraignment a lawyer for the former
president confirmed his indictment
shortly after the initial announcement
the AP reported in a March 18th truth
social post Trump said he would be
arrested on the 21st and called for
people to protest and take our nation
back okay so basically after that they
postpone the indictment things get
delayed then a bunch of people who are
you know conservative but not pro-trump
started saying Trump's grifting he's
lying it's not going to happen then
today they announced I think it was
today they announced the grand jury was
going to be suspended for a month and
then all of a sudden just like a couple
hours ago they announced they voted to
indict Donald Trump so obviously my
opinion on this as we've talked about it
before is this is silly and stupid but
while we have you man what do you think
uh I mean if he committed a crime I
think that he should have the book
thrown at him I think generally this is
a misdemeanor crime usually there's a
statute of limitations but
um if records were falsified in an
attempt to cover up another crime then
the statute of limitations is extended
but I don't think any of us have seen
the indictment yet so I wait till they
unseal the indictment to see how silly
stupid I think it is but hey if you
broke the law I think you should have
the book thrown at him I have an
ex-president I don't believe are above
the law so I absolutely agree I'd like
to see more presidents get arrested in
church oh I mean it makes me nervous
guys that's the first time in history a
president's ever been indicted you know
I I agree I don't care if if they break
the law then they should be charged my
issue I suppose is it seems overtly
political I mean how can we say that
without saying the indictment that's a
fair point but you just said that but it
seems overtly political we don't know
for sure but it seems that way
especially considering the dude
campaigned on investigating Trump they
spent years and this was the best they
could come up with that Cohen paid
Stormy Daniels to not write a book or
give an interview or whatever about
banging Trump and that Trump tried
claiming it was legal fees despite the
fact that a letter was put out 2018
where Cohen Cohen's lawyer said Cohen
paid for it out of pocket was never
reimbursed so I mean like that feels
kind of like exculpatory evidence
outright which makes the scene political
so do you think that the payments to him
that were recorded in the book do you
think that's all fake or I so
I don't know well definitely I'm I'm
interested in seeing what what you know
what the reason I don't understand
because like the thing that drives me
the crazy so how much do they entertain
stuff too where things will come out and
people immediately say this is political
it's partisan it's like why not just
wait till these diamonds come out and
then we can actually see when these
diamonds come out it might be that
there's a lot of stuff in there it's
like oh okay that's fair and it might be
wow this is BS like it's obviously
because Brad campaigned on doing this
sure but I mean like people can campaign
on all sorts of things right Julian a
campaign New York the guy well
if you campaign on like enforcing laws
like is that a political no he's
campaigned on investigating Trump maybe
I thought Trump broke some laws and but
I mean like yeah I mean it seems like a
fair thing to campaign John show me the
man I'll show you the the law that he
broke right well we're about to see that
show and watching a diapers are until so
here's here's what I think with the the
potential of this case you have a lawyer
I imagine you've gone through legal
stuff right um not like a dedicated one
but I've yeah I have a couple depending
on what I'm going through yeah do you go
through their itemized invoices you
might I mean I'm I don't know if you do
or not um I've never made a single
payment of over ten thousand dollars to
a lawyer so usually they send me the
itemized thing and I just they built by
every 15 minutes or 10 minutes or
whatever these bills that Trump's paying
are over hundreds of thousands of
dollars I think for Cohen wasn't it like
330 000 or something at the end of the
day something like that and so
I really doubt Trump was handed this
invoice looked at and said no no we
can't we can't say we paid stormy that's
illegal let's falsify This Record he
probably got a legal bill was like just
pay him I don't know whatever right did
it wasn't the didn't Cohen claim that he
and Trump had personal conversations
about this particular issue yes after
the fact but in 2018 Cohen's lawyer
claimed Cohen paid for it personally
without instruction from Trump and was
never reimbursed for it sure do you
think has Cohen claimed otherwise though
after the fact yes claimed otherwise so
and those times were under uh oath
correct uh then he should be charged
with perjury if that's the case but was
the the statements by his his boss were
those statements under oath his boss
yeah or the other lawyer yeah the other
lawyer were those under oath I'm I don't
know who the letter was filed with so
something that Rosenberg said that I
think was really important when he was
asked for um questioning this was like
three or four years ago I think is uh he
would get very irritated when he was
brought before Congress and claims of
the media I think Jim Jordan did this to
him he the claims in the media be
brought before him and they'd say well
what do you think about this so what do
you think about that I don't think
that's true it's like do you think
they're lying and something Rosenstein
said was well if you think they're lying
bring them and have them testify under
oath so I think it's important when we
look at people's statements people say a
lot of things we saw this with Giuliani
and his companies about Trump people say
a lot of things and then when they're
under oath their stories change
significantly so I'd always be cautious
to compare statements made under oath to
something that some guy might have just
said in a letter or said to the press or
said to a friend who's Rosenstein I
think this was sent to the Federal
Election Commission
uh maybe yeah that's what it says via
email Federal Election Commission Office
of compliance examination and legal
Administration attention Crystal Dennis
and the letter says that Cohen did it of
his own volition he paid for it out of
pocket he was never reimbursed so I I
would put it this way it seems political
when you have a letter like this from
years ago from five years ago and but
but again fair point we'll see what
happens my my issue with it for the most
part is really
falsified record misdemeanor charge we
you want to get into the debate about
Barack Obama blown up a kid because I I
would absolutely love to talk about that
uh look if they want to give Trump a
misdemeanor charge and slap me and lock
them up for however many months a
misdemeanor gets them I would absolutely
be willing to make that to agree you're
right he's got to be charged next up
Obama he blew up a kid a bunch of kids I
don't know if Obama broke a law
I think I don't think Americans of any
capacity are allowed to kill other
Americans of any capacity don't cops do
it all the time not like I mean it seems
like they in the service a little bit of
a semantic trick you played there right
okay
obviously you can kill people in
self-defense but Obama bombed a civilian
restaurant in Yemen a country we're not
at war with killing civilians including
a 16 year old American citizen like you
can't if you're in the military you
can't just or a cop you can't just go
and kill somebody murder you can't
murder yeah but I imagine the
justification Obama would use was that
this was in defense of U.S interests or
defense of the United States and in his
role as commander-in-chief the president
of the United States has offered why
deference from the Supreme Court for
taking actions in the commission of
protecting the United States even if we
disagree with them yeah I think that's
criminal I mean that's fine but there's
a question of like is it illegal versus
do you think it's criminal like bad
right it's probably bad I guess but like
so so the the Obama administration's
argument was that they were trying to
Target a terrorist leader but I'm not I
mean you make a fair point but I'd be
willing to argue that the president does
not have the authority to bomb countries
we are not at war with well what about
when Trump assassinated suleimani that
was an assassination where was that
taking place in Iraq in Iraq yeah a
country we have an AUM F over an
authorization for use of military force
I don't think the authorization for use
of military force I'm pretty sure we
were on good terms of the regular point
I don't know if we had the ability to do
whatever we wanted in that country that
was a political assassination though our
executive orders that are against the
United States I don't disagree sure I'm
just saying that in general there's
multiple questions going on here we can
say do we um do we think it's wrong or
bad probably I think generally the
United States uh president Killing
American citizens is generally a Bad
Thing unless it's really good
justification for it but the difference
between that versus is it illegal and I
think that the law tends to we argue
about this a little bit before the show
when Trump was doing things at the
border that we thought when I say we
progressives and the left got really mad
at the Supreme Court tend to decide with
him because the president has given why
deference over matters
um I think it was when he was using um
he couldn't get the funding for the
border wall
um oh no no it was over Banning certain
people coming into the country
um when he he named the there were seven
Muslim majority countries and when he
was running for president even Giuliani
said he's trying to find ways to do a
Muslim majority ban technically he's not
allowed to Venezuela North Korea on that
list though yeah well he changed it up I
think after the first one got or didn't
go through for whatever reason but once
he did that ban when people tried to
challenge it the Supreme Court basically
said ah president border he could do
almost anything he wants because it's
the president yeah but that's not
blowing up a kid I didn't say it was
blowing up a kid but I've been saying
that in general you would think that
like we're talking like border uh if
we're talking about like passing policy
at the border that seems like a
congressional thing like we should be
passing laws about immigration but the
president can do that basically all on
his own because the Supreme Court's like
he's the president National Security he
can do almost whatever he wants I think
I think I think I think I think I see
the disconnect
I'm I'm less concerned with legality
okay I'm only talking legalities right
so I think that a President Who bombs a
country we're not at war with should be
stripped of his power and criminally
charged for killing an American citizen
and it should be literally under the U.S
murder statutes that are covered by
multiple state and federal laws
I don't I I don't look at it like well
you know is it murder statute could I in
Tennessee get arrested if I bomb
somebody in Yemen is that a I don't know
what the I mean that's a good point you
might yeah absolutely I mean that might
be like way worse than murder it might
be terroristic International uh there
might like I'm pretty sure if you as an
American citizen set up a bomb in a
foreign country you'd be criminally
charged in the US
state statutes right that sounds like
Federal International Federal yeah maybe
Julian Assange is being criminally
charged in the U.S even though he's not
a U.S citizen who didn't do anything in
the United States kim.com for that
matter too I mean the dudes never even
been that was never this country and
they went after him so I just think that
when we I think it's really important
that we separate conversations of what
should somebody be charged with versus
like what do we think is wrong and I
think both conversations are important
we could talk about like is this wrong
or is it not wrong and there's probably
a good conversation we have there but
there's a difference between that versus
like somebody needs to be charged here
he's like charged with what is there
actually a crime broken or is it just
like we're really upset about this
particular thing which is fair yeah I
think the Patriot acts insane in the
National Defense authorization act
insane it gives them I mean it really
gives the president the authority to
bomb an American citizen anywhere it
doesn't it gives them the right to
rendition anyone anywhere in the world
and then hold secret tribunals and I
think that's wrong and I think if we're
gonna just play like the question of is
it legal well then there's a whole lot
of really awful stuff the government's
gonna end up doing if we just say well
they made it legal so they can do it but
yeah but this is what I always fight
against like when it comes to like BLM
and everything too
um it's important to change the law so
we want people to be held accountable we
have to change the laws to reflect what
we think our moral will is so that we
can actually get people to be held
accountable because otherwise you just
get a bunch of people like this is wrong
do something it's like okay well I don't
know what you want us to do like it's
not illegal like we can't do anything
about it you know if we changed the law
and it made it illegal to bomb kids in
Yemen then we wouldn't be able to charge
people that were doing it while it was
legal because it was legal when they
yeah probably but I mean do we want to
make it so that when we change laws we
can retroactively right I don't anyway
like I don't we're probably I don't
think we're ever officially at war with
Syria right no but Trump bombed the
airport is that like but again he's the
president it's our military like I guess
the other question is is you know in
talking about abdulrahman Allah he
wasn't the intended target the intended
target was somebody else and he and he
had just a few weeks prior killed Anwar
al-alaki Abdul rahman's dad so he kills
this guy who's an American citizen then
argues well look you know he was a
Jihadi he was preaching against the
United States he had to be stopped but
then a few weeks later he targets a
civilian restaurant in Yemen blows up
this restaurant with a drone strike
killing a killing anwal a lucky son
abdulrahman and the response was well we
were targeting a terror leader so it's
okay so I guess the question is
I'm I'm curious as to the legalities and
the moral standing of one does the
president have the legal authority to
kill anyone in any country at any time
in the eyes of the United States
if he does and hits the wrong target and
kills an innocent American citizen is
there a manslaughter similar charge for
this kind of conflict I think
internationally uh unfortunately I think
we just don't tend to hold countries
responsible this has happened multiple
times I'll avoid the USS Liberty example
because that's a whole loaded thing but
uh there was let's see I think Iran
after we killed suleimani in the night
or the night after that followed Iran
accidentally shot down I think one of
their own civilian airliners and there
were no charges nothing was held for
that
um I believe in Iran in Iran yeah I mean
they're like authoritarian though you
know true no I'm just saying but
internationally um I believe it happened
over Ukraine as well I think that there
was a missile launched from Crimea I
believe that was probably with the
assistance of Russian troops there there
was a civilian airliner shot down there
that nothing happened the United States
I believe
um I think we shut down a civilian plane
that killed like over 150 over 200
people that might have been south of
Iran I think flying towards Saudi Arabia
maybe and and we didn't do anything
about that we said sorry but I think
that was like 200 or so somebody said I
mean it happens it sucks but I mean
precedent internationally is that like
sometimes mistakes happen countries do
mistakes they're bad and you pay money
sometimes but there's usually not like
Criminal Courts for those types of
mistakes but it was proven then yeah of
course we say
um you know the best I could do on short
notice the ACL ACL you wrote an article
saying that it was unlawful
well if the ACLU said it no I mean yeah
it's it's when they said which was
unlawful the the not just the killing of
Abdullahi but the other civilians that
were killed in these in these countries
went out of war with was it says the
killing program isn't only unlawful it's
unwise and that's about you know on the
short term there have been legal
arguments made that Obama does have the
right to kill Americans abroad but I
kind of feel like you know we've got
multiple amendments that afford American
citizens a plethora of Rights before
they can just kill you so that's where
that's where I'm at on the issue I
suppose do you still have American
rights when you're in another country
you still pay taxes so yes you do and
the state department will send guys to
rescue if you're kidnapped maybe um this
is the first I've heard of the USS
Liberty that you mentioned earlier oh
God no don't even do it 1967. during the
Israeli Six-Day War they accidentally
torpedoed or they shot down uh yeah but
depending on who you ask it's not an
accident that's like a whole can of
worms of why we are Jewish let's let's
uh let's let's jump to this next story
from timcast.com quote political
persecution election interference at the
highest level in history Trump responds
to indictment will reportedly surrender
early next week never before no nation's
history has this been done the statement
from Trump let's pull it up let's read
it here we go if I can Texas kind of
small he writes this is political
persecution and election interference to
the highest level in history from the
time I came down the golden escalator
truck tower and even before I was sworn
as sworn in as your president of the
United States the radical left Democrats
the enemy of hard-working men and women
of this country have been engaged in a
Witch Hunt to destroy the make America
great again movement you remember it
just like I do Russia Russia Russia the
Mueller hoax Ukraine Ukraine Ukraine
impeachment hoax one impeachment hoax 2
the illegal and unconstitutional
Mar-A-Lago raid and now this the
Democrats have lied cheated and stolen
in their obsession with trying to get
Trump but now they've done the
unthinkable indicting a completely
innocent person in an act of blatant
election interference never before our
nation's history has this been done
the Democrats Have Cheated countless
times of the Decades including spying on
my campaign but weaponizing our justice
system to punish a political opponent
who just so happens to be a president of
the United States and by far the leading
Republican candidate for president has
never happened before ever Manhattan D.A
Alvin Bragg who was hand-picked and
funded by George Soros is a disgrace
rather than stopping the unprecedented
crime wave taking over New York City
he's doing Joe Budden's Dirty Work
ignoring the murders and burglaries and
assaults he should be focused on this is
how Bragg spends his time I believe this
Witch Hunt will backfire massively on
Joe Biden the American people realize
exactly what the radical left Democrats
are doing here everyone can see it so
our movement and our party UNIF United
United and strong will first defeat
Alvin Bragg and then we will defeat Joe
Biden and we are going to throw every
last one of these crooked Democrats out
of office so he can make America great
again
well very interesting
what do you think
they better be doing a really good job
at that office
um I think there's a lot of political
consideration has to go into these
charges because it is
um it is a it's a really scary world
when your criminal justice system is
potentially interfering with an election
which is something that
um despite what some Americans think
that's all of our intelligence agencies
try really hard to avoid this exact
scenario where you might be indicting or
arresting or charging with crimes like
somebody that could be running for
president so I hope that whatever they
have I hope when these indictments are
unsealed some really solid stuff and
it's not just a whole bunch of like you
know Lucy whatever that ends up falling
apart what do you think about uh he
mentions Ukraine what do you think do
you remember the whole Ukraine gate
Fiasco impeachment
um Donald Trump quid pro quo yep I do
remember that yeah what are your
thoughts uh am I allowed to say the f
word uh after 15 seconds yeah I mean we
try to keep it first 108 seconds they
demonetized yeah I think that's fine I'm
I'm okay with that impeachment if that's
what you're asking you you think Trump
committed a crime with absolutely you
want to elaborate I know it might be a
bit it's been a long time it's been a
while but my understanding was that
Trump contacted Ukraine zielinski and he
was asking if there was wrongdoing done
by um I think it was by Biden and
finding that prosecutor and if they had
any information about potential
wrongdoings that Hunter Biden or Joe
Biden have been involved in in Ukraine
and in exchange for that he wanted to
withhold a that was already
congressionally approved to Ukraine for
that so what's wrong with that like why
is why is that was that a problem
um legally or morally or both either or
whatever legally I believe it's because
I don't think the president has the
authority to withhold that Aid I don't
remember what the legal arguments were
on that
um for the the moral part is our
precedent probably shouldn't be asking
other countries to investigate like
wrongdoings of political opponents
that's a really like Joe Biden wasn't
running for office at the time
um I mean why was he hold on I'm trying
to think of the timeline for this yeah
Joe Biden it was a year before he
announced
that was that was part of the
controversy that Joe Biden had not
announced he was running for office at
all no but hold on he might not have
announced it but like pretty sure most
people knew he was running like in the
early polls like if you looked at real
uh is it real clear progress if you
looked at a lot of the polling aggregate
sites like they were already polling
Biden he'd already been factored in
quite a while he might have announced
that he was going to run for office but
I'm pretty sure a lot of people were
expecting it I mean I mean that's just
speculative Media stuff so Trump isn't
actively investigating a political
opponent unless the argument is we all
secretly knew that was going to be the
case they were like Bernie Sanders was
still in the race there were a bunch of
other people at the time the controversy
was like why would Joe Biden there were
there were other Democrats that were
actually talking about running and it
wasn't Joe Biden he announced late he
did announce late but he was still
factored at the polls really early
because a lot of people thought he was
going to run the question is though is
that do we want the president contacting
other even if he's not running it's
still a typical the vice president did
the same thing is that if the vice
president was I think any time you're
reaching out like let's ask if we pull
back on a macro level why is Trump
asking this information does he
genuinely think that there's been some
grave wrongdoing done by the bidens that
needs to be corrected for yeah and if so
why isn't he asking our intelligence
agencies for information about this why
is he going to another country and
asking I mean I don't we it's with the
five I spy club we do that all the time
it is when we go to we don't do that all
the time going to another leader and
saying hey I need you to get dirt on a
potential political opponent because I
think there's something well he wasn't a
political opponent and he is he was the
vice president of the former opposite
party guy that he just um as he came
into office what do you mean he's some
kind of political opponent right even if
he's even if he wasn't directly running
yet like I would argue any if he was
asking this over like AOC for instance
Trump I would say that it's similar
Trump didn't go to the president of
Ukraine and say I got this political
opponent I need dirt on he said what's
up with this video of Joe Biden
threatening to withhold congressionally
approved Aid unless you take action on
his behalf and the president of Ukraine
was like I'm not sure anyways well can
you look into that I want to know what
that's about it wasn't just can you look
into that it was if if you don't find
what I need I might withhold a that's
already been congressionally approved
for you and that was the issue if he was
just asking questions we wouldn't be
having the conversation it was impeached
right so this is the point that I'm
getting at when when this started and
Donald Trump asked about this
specifically because there was a viral
video of Joe Biden outright admitting to
threatening to withhold congressionally
approved Aid unless a prosecutor got
fired you had Joe Biden breaking the law
sure so there was a video of Joe Biden
on stage making the claim slash joke on
stage where he's saying I told him you
don't do it you're not going to blah
blah blah blah blah but in terms of him
like well but in terms of there actually
being a serious offer on the table where
he was like threatening to withhold Aid
I'm not even sure if that was ever the
case it would have that one statement
that he was made Victory number one
signed a sworn affidavit that is what
happened number one number two the
impetus for Shogun being removed from
Ukraine was not to get some kind of
political dirt on on an opponent it was
a completely different scenario this is
a prosecutor that all of Europe and and
over half of Ukraine wanted fired that
the United States was acting on behalf
of the western world and trying to
pressure this prosecutor out because of
his lack of Prosecuting corruption in
the country that's a totally different
thing than I threatened to withhold aid
from this guy because he's not giving me
dirt on potential political opponents so
why is it that the guy who was being
investigated my my colaslachevsky
returned to the country he had fled when
shoken was was investigating him and
then after Joe Biden got choked and
removed zlachevsky returned to the
country to begin working on bursma again
why did he return to the country so so I
could have been for any number of reason
I'm not sure right so the argument from
the Democrats the specific corruption
that wasn't being prosecuted referring
to is the prosecution of mikola
zlachevsky the the founder of barisma
okay and the argument they made was he
wasn't investigating him that was the
problem and then Joe Biden says and we
we got we got him out and then they put
in someone solid the only issue is when
shoken had about a dozen active
investigations into barisma and
slachevsky zlachevsky fled the country
they tried they froze his account when
Biden came in and got the prosecutor
fired zlachevski safely returned to
Ukraine without fear of criminal
prosecution When Donald Trump made that
phone call zlachevsky fled again
so it sounds more like it's like so uh
you've got Hunter Biden on the board of
barisma you got a former CIA director on
the board of barisma and zlachevsky the
founder and shoken was invested he had
12 different and active around 12 to 14.
all of the investigations into barisma
were dead no they weren't that's not
true it was wrong absolutely true
completely they were only revived one
month before shokun was forced out now
every single one of those probes was
completely dead that that's that's wrong
I mean you can Google and look for it if
you want okay so I'm citing Matt taibi
oh God right and if you don't if you
don't want to trust a journalist or
whatever or like any actual like article
not a tweet like like anything actually
I'm talking about an article that he
wrote breaking down what happened with
Ukraine and his investigation into
tlalzewsky and this is from like 20s
okay so your claim is that um the probes
into barismo never went cold and never
died that they were active the entire
time they they were active the entire
right okay my understanding is that
those probes were all cold and all dead
and it was part of them dead before nice
and cold it's the same thing they were
being actively worked on so there were
probes that nobody was doing anything
with them until it was one month before
shokun was actually ousted that there
was some progress started to be made on
that so that that's a very difficult
question to get into the fact is there
were active investigations well but
that's kind of the meat of what we're
talking about right well so it's kind of
important to settle the fact of the
matter of that yeah were there 12
investigations yes or no they're I know
that their investigations open for a
couple years but my understanding is
that's all open it's not all that
matters they were dead investigations
being made out of it that's what I read
it was reported right my point is this
but that's pretty important because if
they're being actively investigated then
that obviously changes a little bit the
story that we're telling you so did
shoken have investigations into into
barisma and slachevsky yes he had about
a dozen but whether or not live or dead
is that important you don't think so did
zlotchesky flee the country while these
were on the books
yes you did I don't know when shokin was
removed and the and the investigations
were officially stricken zlachevsky
returns so do you think that there are
criminal wrongdoings that he's done that
he's not being prosecuted for
what I think is that the United States
is in in an energy crisis in a war with
Eastern Powers the United States has
been trying to get a pipeline for
natural gas called the cutter turkey
pipeline into Europe but Syria said no
Syria destabilizes for whatever reason
we want to run that pipeline through
Syria through turkey into Europe to
offset the gas prom gas Monopoly Russia
runs natural gas into Europe through
Ukraine through gas prom it's about 20
percent it's massively powerful for them
and allows them to control prices the
United States has interests in setting
up an energy company to offset that
Monopoly hence barisma Hunter Biden's on
the board probably for these reasons a
former CIA director probably for this
was one of the smaller gas companies in
that country and absolutely and it seems
like the U.S was trying to compete with
Russia to get cheaper gas to Europe and
the argument made was that Europe was
constrained by high gas prices from
Russia and that we wanted the European
economy to be bolstered and grow faster
to compete with China but Russia was
basically keeping us pinned down sure
this is nice conjecture but like is
there anything back in up any of this
aside from like this is all the official
reporting what do you mean by official
reporting so there's official reporting
that we should have choking because we
wanted to bolster U.S interests that's
the only speculation I have I'm saying
based on the facts it seems to me the
issue was shokin did have investigations
into Prisma which was a problem for U.S
interests not because of corruption but
because we're it's a it's more of a war
front it's more of a do you think do you
think that Shogun was a corrupt
prosecutor no okay why did all of Europe
and a lot of Ukraine hate him because
Europe wants cheap gas
was impeding that it's that issue of
corruption it's an issue of conflicting
it how so active investigations into
barisma are impeding U.S interests in
competing with gas Charisma isn't even
the largest gas player in that country
though that's not the point we didn't we
don't have the cutter tricky pipeline
into Ukraine because Syria blocked it so
you have a multi-front effort going back
to I think like the 2000s to get cheaper
natural gas into Europe so of course
they're not going to like anybody who's
got Eastern allegiances it's it's
possible that with Ukraine you had in
the eastern part of the country more
pro-russia sentiment with yanakovich you
had more pro-russia sentiment and you
had government officials that were like
look we are not just Pro west of course
then he gets ousted there's a there's a
there's unrest uh I can't really mean
for janakovich though Yanukovych was
standing alone with that pro-russian
status though that wasn't all the
government officials that was part of
the reasons why people were so upset
with ianakovich was because right he was
trying to to push for Russia in
opposition to what their Parliament was
even pushing that's what I'm saying and
so there's probably he wasn't the only
person that sent was fairly split but
was leaning towards the EU had been
voted on by their Parliament like to
favor the EU that was what the right is
for and so the the way I see it is there
are probably elements of that government
that were more favorable to Russia which
is why Europe doesn't like them the the
people ukrainians who want to be a part
of the EU members of the EU who want
Ukraine to join because they want more
control over natural gas of course
naturally would oppose anybody who is
siding with Russia do you think that
Ukraine was a corrupt country prior to
2014 yes okay I mean it's do you think
so when so for all of Europe and for
everybody complaining about the
corruption
um and stuff relating to shokun you
think that all of that was BS and they
just didn't like him because he was
preventing their cheap oil or cheap gas
say that one more time do you think that
all of the upsettedness that people
across Europe and Ukraine had with
shoken had nothing to do with any of the
corruption in the country or the lack of
pressuring because like that's the
official story of this cabinet it seems
to be like pretty consistent throughout
like I can only I can only speak on a
surface level about this one particular
issue because I don't know the inner
workings of all of Ukrainian politics
okay but what I do know is there's been
a tremendous effort by Western forces
leading to outright physical military
conflict to get natural gas into Europe
to offset Russia's control of gas prices
naturally it seems like these things are
related speculative the facts are the
U.S went to Syria and said can we build
the cutter turkey pipeline Syria
literally said the United States that
would be bad for our Ally Russia so we
will not allow it
for fortunately for us for whatever
reason Syria falls into Civil War and we
just happen to oppose the guy who denied
that I don't think the whole reason for
opposing it has to do with gas but it's
convenient for us nonetheless we weren't
able to do it and to make it worse Iran
wanted to tap the same natural gas field
and send the gas through Iraq and turkey
into Europe to strengthen Russia's
control of energy so the the argument
was the EU is trying to grow and become
a unified block to compete with the
growth of China and Russia was basically
impeding us because Russia wants to be
their own big dog right sure let's so
um man if you ever wanted to re uh
revisit a detailed breakdown of this
you'd be interested to do a little bit
of reading prior to this but let's say
let's say hypothetically I grant you all
of that why didn't Trump say any of that
Trump doesn't know what the what the
hell is going on okay so then Trump's
investigation into so the impetus of
this whole conversation bro okay so yeah
so the evidence for this whole
conversation of like Trump pressuring
them to find out if any wrongdoors
haven't had nothing to do with anything
you just laid out it was just having to
do with Hunter Biden and Joe Biden it
had to do with him seeing a video and
then seeing people and post memes
probably to be completely honest it was
Tucker Carlson sure who said something
but it was a little bit more than just
asking questions because if he was just
curious I don't think that the the
question of Aid being withheld would
have ever been brought up in that
conversation so clearly there was a
little bit you're saying that Biden
wasn't seen as a political opponent at
all but if that was the case I don't
know why Trump would go so far to try to
solicit information from the Ukrainian
government such that he would withhold
Aid or threaten to withhold Aid in
exchange for some information about him
you know whether it seems like a random
politician to Target like why would he
be so dead set on getting information
about Pfizer Democrats they were calling
him a Russian spy
you can think that but I'm not even I'm
not I don't even care all that much
about the speculation as to why he did
it right sure if you want to argue well
I think that's probably one of the most
important parts that is the most
important part is why he did it but you
guys have a few assumptions to get to
that point
do I if he's asking for dirt
specifically with respect to a political
opponent I'm making assumptions I feel
like there's a lot more assumptions
being made on your end that he was just
genuinely interested in what Joe Biden
had said and was threatening to withhold
a because he wanted a legitimate
investigation of the firing of a
prosecutor
I'm I mean I feel like it's really
legitimate is what we know is that he
said what's going on with this video I
want to see some action on this or else
right
I feel like there was a little bit more
so than that but I don't remember it's
been a long time well I'm just I'm just
trying to paraphrase paraphrase for the
same sure but I feel like the the
specific request he was making for
information are probably pretty
important I could look up exactly what
the charges of alleged but it's been a
while but so I guess the reason I bring
it up is not to just debate Trump or
whatever but but to ask the question of
should we indict Joe Biden for doing the
same thing I don't believe Joe Biden did
the same thing though the request and
who it was on behalf of was Far
different than but Joe Biden does not
have the authority to threaten to
withhold congression I don't know if Joe
Biden actually threatened to withhold
Aid report that was it on camera that he
did he said he said something on camera
that I don't know literally said on
camera I told him that if you don't fire
the prosecutor knocking the billion
dollars and he said you don't have the
authority to do that I said call the
president ask him see what he says well
son of a six hours later he's
fired Trump also said on camera they
could shoot somebody on 6th Street and
not get arrested for it but that's
different from admitting to declinic
crimes I don't know if Biden admitted to
a crime there or if he was just talking
Biden also was in front of an
audience saying that he had what like
170 IQ and graduated from Harvard Law or
something right he obviously didn't do
that right so I don't know when Biden is
on stage like oh I told him I was gonna
lose it I don't know if he's just like
you know we got his big boy pants on
he's talking he actually did do
that and he didn't have the authority to
do it and it was on behalf of some
selfish or whatever then yeah I think
there should obviously be an
investigation or something the fact that
there's never been an official statement
confirming that there's never been any
um aside from the Ukrainian officials
confirming that and the maybe there
should be everything relating to that
yeah but every time Republicans say
there should be and they go and look
they find nothing okay but whether it's
Benghazi whether it's Hillary's emails
whether it's uh
no the Hillary's email stuff is was
there like that's that's not even we
don't know if Hillary Clinton gave a
command to delete stuff that should have
been deleted to impede an investigation
we don't know that information which is
what the charge would have been for sure
sure we know that she had a server with
35 000 emails on it we know that there's
staff smashed hammers we know that um
one of our staffers I guess he went on
Reddit and he said how can I purge
emails with someone's name on it or
something like that sure and like I
think didn't he get charged or something
I don't know okay I think it was granted
immunity in exchange for information
yeah yeah that's crazy right I remember
when that happened like some dude on
Reddit found the account and they were
like I think this guy worked sure but
the crime that we were looking for was
whether Hillary Clinton ordered
classified emails to be deleted which
doesn't seem like that was we spent a
whole lot of time talking about that and
for all the complaining that we do about
a judge indicting Trump or intelligence
agencies interfering elections Comey
coming out of making the statements that
he did about Hillary Clinton were not
only unprecedented but also potentially
election altering too so I mean do you
think
Barack Obama ordering a drone strike
that killed an American citizen warrants
an investigation of that
um there might have already been an
investigation I don't know what the the
vetting process inside of orders from
the government like whether whether
there wasn't do you think there should
have been
um yeah there probably always should be
when there's collateral damage didn't it
happen um was it in Afghanistan or
Pakistan wasn't there a hospital that we
accidentally bombed like a year and a
half ago I think probably I think like
20 or 30 people died and it was all
civilians like yeah anytime something
that happens there should obviously be
some type of oversight and that's
different between like there needs to be
a criminal charge for an intentionally
destructive act done right you agree
that there's a world of difference
between
um Biden ordered an American citizen
killed overseas versus American citizen
dies as a result of collateral damage
from a drone strike those two things are
Worlds Apart right well the added
context is we're not at war with this
country and it doesn't matter even if we
are at the country there's still Worlds
Apart right
so we'll slow down for a second sure my
question is very simply if we're not to
the president does not extend to bombing
any random country well it seems like
that's not where we're at legally right
now right I think it's we're not it's
where we're it's not where we're at
because the American people don't do
anything about it did we vote in
Congress to bomb the Syrian airport when
Trump returned fire for whatever gas
attacks no but I think there's something
different to an active war zone we do
have troops on the ground in and I don't
agree with it war with Syria we have we
have ground troops we have we haven't
declared a war since since World War II
I don't but we didn't even have a UA uh
uh yeah I don't agree with Trump's
firing I'm just saying that like like if
an American citizen even would have died
on the base yeah I'm just saying that
we're not voting for war in these areas
right we're still bombing them so it
seems like when you if you're asking me
a moral question versus a legal question
those are two different things if you're
asking me legally it seems like that
seems to be that the president can
indeed order drone strikes on place that
we're not at war with that seems to be
where we're at legally right now morally
should he be able to I don't know I
don't know what the justification is for
that but let's jump to this next story
from the Tampa Bay Times DeSantis says
Florida will not assist impossible Trump
extradition after indictment the Florida
governor weighed in on Twitter he said
the weaponization of the legal system to
advance a political agenda turns the
rule of law on its head it is an
American The soros-backed Manhattan D.A
has consistently bent the law to
downgrade felonies and to excuse
criminal misconduct yet now he is and
there's a second tweet here
where is it at
wait oh okay yet now he is stretching
the law to Target a political opponent
Florida will not assist in an
extradition request given the
questionable circumstances at issue with
the Soros backed Manhattan prosecutor
and his political agenda uh what are
your thoughts
is he actually sorospect
I think so or was it that like because I
thought that the actual thing was like
George Soros uh contributed to a pack
that has also contributed to him
I think I think it's a little different
but regardless even outside of that I
mean Rhonda Santos saying we're not
going to allow what is he saying we're
not going to extradite right that's what
it says well what you know did he even
really say that he said well not assist
in the extradition it's like a pretty
tepid statement to be completely honest
so I don't even know if there's an
actual question to be asked should
Florida assist in the extradition like
it doesn't matter
well it kind of matters I think it would
I think it matters based on the
precedent of the crime if this is a
crime that they wouldn't normally
extradite for then they probably don't
have an obligation to right like I don't
think California would extradite me if I
had like an outstanding speeding ticket
in Iowa right yeah and this is this
might be a similar thing where they
don't expect but if there was like a if
somebody like did a double homicide in
Florida's like we're not going to extra
item that'd probably be a pretty big
deal but yeah I don't know if a crime
like this if it's I think we're
Expedition is ordinary or not Donald
Trump what's the what's the what's the
charge that he falsified
um a legal bill
well it's that he falsified a legal bill
but it has to be something more than
that right because that charge in and of
itself is a misdemeanor that the statute
of limitations would have expired on so
it said he falsified that legal bill in
the commission or the experiment of
another crime all right I think it's
related to election stuff the argument
was that it pertained to campaign
Finance or they use campaign funds to do
it or something like that because Cohen
billed Trump campaign or whatever but uh
I guess we'll see when the indictment
comes out if they're stretching us up to
a felony my my view is uh it's it's all
overtly political and this country is
being ripped and ripped to shreds so I
don't know if it really matters whether
to Santa is going to do anything or not
it's there whether whether we can have a
debate about it or not no one's going to
agree the end result is just going to be
people on the right saying that Trump is
being politically persecuted and people
are left saying it's Justice well it
only matters for the primary because
desensis this whole time has been trying
to position himself As Trump without the
bad stuff that's sort of his whole brand
but as you go into this more and more
you're going to see that desensis really
isn't a trump guy and he's going to try
and make his own brand of sort of
trumpism but with some other stuff and I
think a lot of the hardcore Trump people
like myself I mean I was a day one 2016
supporter right when he came down the
goal in escalar as I was already sold
but a lot of people that I know in DC or
in sort of these other circles they
think oh well we should move on from
Trump it's time for DeSantis to take
over but I mean the reality is this
whole thing is going to help Trump I
think the mug shot it's gonna be on
t-shirts it's gonna be art like people
are gonna love it uh on the left they're
loving it because they think oh we
finally got him we got the handcuffs on
Donald Trump on the right we're they're
just getting things in martyr can I can
I play this video from Dash dubrowsky
yeah
all right I think I gotta turn it down
Donald Trump has been indicted in
Manhattan the grand jury just voted to
indict
the Trump for his hush money payments to
Stormy Daniels this is big news
like if he's in control his moves when
he goes uh what is he uh been indicted
he tilts his head forward and he gets
Shadow under his eyes and looks real
villainous versus
back up yeah it's awesome
I'm sorry I think highly entertaining
it's
an act I mean obviously yeah I've been
doing this for money when it comes to
stuff like this I think it's really
important that you mentally swap the
people out in your head to figure out
how you feel about it because we have a
huge problem right now in this country
with actually having principal positions
on any issue whatsoever so I
think that when people are trying to
think like should Trump get arrested for
this like think like if it was Hillary
Clinton would you feel the same if it
was AOC would you feel the same if it
was DeSantis would you feel the same I
think it's really important to do these
mental swaps to check for honesty to
make sure that it's not just like you
said like all partisan politics at the
end of the day I agree especially what I
legal systems are involved I agree but I
don't think it's principles I don't
think anyone's principled at all but I'm
not saying that I am too I'm not saying
that from like a dejected you know sense
or like a not like you know I'm jaded in
Black Belt I'm saying it that people
genuinely don't understand the moral
philosophies around principles and their
positions so the example I often give is
when it came to Florida on the parental
rights and education bill you had
conservatives being like parents have
the final say in whether or not their
kids are being exposed to the stuff and
whether or not their kids are going to
get these treatments the teachers have
no right to withhold that information
from the parents and then my response is
in Washington they completely agree that
the parents have final say so when the
parent says the child should get sex
change surgery the government should not
be allowed to intervene to stop it you
see the point the principle is the same
should parents have final say but both
conservatives and and left liberals or
whatever position have a differing view
of when it should be allowed when it
comes to a child deciding they are trans
the left passes law is saying they can
withhold that from parents when it comes
to parents wanting to give their
children sex change surgery
conservatives argue the state should
intervene to stop that so which is it
right
people don't have principles they have
moral foundations and they have lines
that they're willing to Cross or not
cross and so both sides will argue my
principle is X but it does not apply
that's my point sure so I do better I I
don't I mean I don't I don't I don't
think there's a do better or there's a
bad it's quite literally if two factions
of people have different moral standards
that's that's it yeah but I think the
problem is not being honest about those
moral standards like I think that's the
issue because when we're when we argue
for certain principles I think everybody
ends up at the end of the day we're all
attacking like the shadows and the
ghosts of the people that we're arguing
against because nobody actually believes
in a lot of things they're saying and
that hurts our ability to actually move
the conversation forward like there's a
lot of people for instance I think I
even saw this on your Twitter I don't
remember the tweets there's a lot of
conservatives that hate it red
flag laws and now after this trance
shooting a whole bunch of concerns like
well should mentally ill people have
guns I'm not actually sure and it's like
where what changed and that's exactly my
point yeah is that the principle the
principles don't apply to most people
left or right
there are principles there you just have
to dig a little bit deeper so like for
some conservative spiritual just like
trans people I don't want to have
any rights um rather than like I don't I
I don't agree with like red flag laws um
and we just have to get to like the
deeper positions for the extra so we can
fight against those positions I'm I'm
see my thing without red flag laws is
I'm completely in favor of them so long
as they have an adversarial due process
the problem with red flag laws literally
is that they're not adversarial it's
like someone can go to a judge the judge
can issue a written just come and take
your guns whereas due process requires
your your rights to confront an accuser
to file a rebuttal to say no and then
actually have a chance to have proper
adjudication so I used to not be in
favor of it until it was actually
conservatives who argued that through
due process your rights can be curtailed
hence like being put in prison if you
break the law and then a Court gives you
due process and says you broke the law
we can literally lock you in a box and
take everything away from you and I'm
like okay fair point in that case if
you're mentally ill and then someone
files a claim saying you're a risk to
yourself and a harm harm to yourself or
others then you should have the right to
receive a notice in the mail answer that
claim reject it and then have a judge
actually issue a standard due process if
you're in prison you can't have guns you
know I mean like we so if there is is
some standard by which we believe you
are a threat and you are going to cause
harm then you have a right to challenge
that in court same as any other criminal
charge you have and then if you lose and
I think that that is a defensible that
argument is defensible
but it's not defensible if it only comes
up when a trans person goes on a
shooting space I completely agree right
so it seems like there's because there's
a lot of arguments against
um red flag laws that are still standing
that like those arguments didn't go away
like I'm I lean I'm probably against red
flag laws it leans slightly against them
just because I feel like it makes it so
hard
um if you're a guy that likes guns and
you've got like mental issues man going
to a therapist becomes really
scary because what if you get a
diagnosis that is now precluding you
from owning Firearms
um and now you've got to show up in
court and you've got to fight a judge
for your Second Amendment right which is
very important one in the United States
um that gets hairy and depending on how
people you know represent red flag laws
or what type they're pushing for
um
yeah it is a really scary thing but uh
yeah I'm just saying that that's a good
point that's a challenge it reminds me
of the uh it reminds me of the the do
you guys know BoJack Horseman yeah yeah
it's like that scene with the you know
saying the women carry guns and she's in
front of Congress and she's like well
you know if you don't want women to
carry guns because you're worried about
what's going to happen then you either
have to ban all guns you've got to let
women do and they like ban all guns like
okay well that's kind of what it feels
like happened with a transgender thing
uh with with the after the shooting
because they're like well maybe it is
really important that we look at the
mental health of people that have guns
and like everyone in the lab is like
what the we're like yeah of course
but well I agree I think if someone goes
on Prozac You could argue that they're
not mentally well for a gun if someone's
an alcoholic 25 of a Americans
at this point though yeah
Pharmaceuticals that's scary and there's
another interesting thing when I talk
about when I was in LA in Venice and you
got those guys selling weed cards and
they're like I'm walking down the street
going to the skatepark and this guy goes
I mean you get your weed card yet you
get weed card and I'm like no no he's
like why not why don't you have your
weed card and I'm like I don't need one
it's like I'm not sick and he goes oh
you skateboard right and I'm like yeah
he's like don't you like hurt your legs
or whatever and I was like yeah
sometimes my knees he goes oh bro you
got knee problems oh you need some meat
you need some weed you gotta get a weed
card doctor will get you signed up not
interested you get that weed card you
smoke weed you you aren't eligible you
can't own a gun maybe for physical pain
you could buy you could get away with it
but for if you say it's stress you're no
no no no wait wait wait that's not the
Peru are you saying it could
theoretically be true with red flag laws
um on the form it asks you if you are a
user of Narcotics and so the risk is if
you have a weed prescription card yes
you are and that means you will be
ineligible for owning a gun it's insane
huh yeah so you ever see the what are
they called the forms you fill out we
have to buy a gun it asks you if you're
a user of Narcotics
and they have it classified federally as
a schedule one narcotic right it's like
the worst possible one if you have a
weed card I don't think you'll be able
to argue you weren't lying they're going
to say you have a weed card prescription
like to do this drug there's no shot I
can't believe that I've never heard it
it's that's actually real that anyone's
ever had their guns taken away because
they had a weed card I've never heard
that I can see that argument and you
know what I know that's not the case
because if that was I would have heard
conservatives complaining about it they
want 100 by and arrested over it because
he filled out a form and said he wasn't
a drug user when he's a crackhead no no
but that's
um that's literally why they want him
arrested for Hunter Biden Hunter Biden
filled out a form the form was released
publicly and on it he said he was not a
drug user despite the 4473 for a gun the
background check form for a gun
it asks you if you're a user of
Narcotics I feel like they wanted him
arrested because they said that he's
doing illegal dealings overseas where
he's roping his father into the
specifically for the gun issue it was
like his girlfriend or whatever his wife
threw the gun in a dumpster behind his
school did they accurately date the
crack use though for when he filled out
the form that was the question is the
argument he quit doing crack a long time
ago thus he was saying no and the
argument was he's like still a crackhead
they found a crack pipe in his car on
some time or whatever and so
I am not saying overtly and outright
every single person Whoever has a weed
card will never be able to buy a gun
again I'm saying if they want grounds to
take your weapons and you have had a
weed card they will come they will have
a a notice and they will say look you
have a weed card you're a user tell it
to a judge we're taking your guns
they'll use it as a pretext
wait hold on okay I looked up the 4470
things are curious now so it says oh
well so it says are you an unlawful user
of marijuana so I would say if you've
got the card you're probably not
unlawful
maybe it would be you would you would
absolutely be they actually say on the
Forum I'm pretty sure it says note
regardless of local laws see what it
says it says that right
yeah it says uh possession of marijuana
remains unlawful under federal law
regardless whether it's been legal like
oh well government's coming from my
gun soon completely insane you're like
oh crap
I've never heard of like the ATF Crush
referencing databases to like ax guns
from people that have like legal
marijuana cards or whatever but they can
if they want to theoretically maybe we
got news ladies and gentlemen we have
information on the Trump indictment
breaking Trump indicted reportedly on 34
counts related to falsifying business
records the indictment stems from Trump
allegedly falsifying records concerning
130 000 payment to Daniel Stormy Daniels
in 2016. CNN reports they were informed
of the number of indictments by an
unnamed source so we we take that um
with grain of salt Trump's former
attorney Michael Cohen pleaded guilty
yada yada let's play the clip from CNN
do we have audio here my sources that
this is 34 counts of falsification of
business records uh which is probably a
lot of charges uh involving each
document each thing that was submitted
as a separate count
um in a couple of matters
okay well that's it is that like if he's
like yeah and then he responds it has to
be more than that
more than what it has to be more than
just counts of falsifying business
records I think it has to be something
election related to keep it to go past
the misdemeanor thing I think I'm gonna
I'm gonna I'm gonna agree I I think it's
definitely going to be more than just
the Stormy Daniels thing falsifying
business or gazelle if they're in an
email chain and he's like are you sure
and then he sends email he's like
responds yes and then he's like okay
then is that three counts my guess is
gonna be that I think he was paid back
wasn't it over a multi like a year
period or a two year period the
falsifying business let's say that I
paid you bi-weekly over an entire year
right it would be 26 different payments
that I'm lying about so it'd probably be
26 separate counts of falsifying records
that'd be my guess but again it has to
be more than just falsifying records
because that's only a misdemeanor and
the statute of limitations expired and
it's a misdemeanor why we charge
a president
that's the most insane thing from
conservatives it has to be something
more than that
um it has to be something more than that
but I agree I think they're gonna it's
gonna be worse than people think right
now everyone's saying it's a Stormy
Daniels thing I bet it's gonna be
something else something completely
different I don't know about completely
different but it's going to be it's got
to be really like campaign fund
misappropriation or the question the
question is something will it be dubious
or will it be questionable or will it be
airtight you know what I mean I kind of
feel like it's probably going to be
dubious I mean Ukraine gate as it was
and and and Mueller and Russia and all
that stuff did not pan out
in terms of indictments are a lot of
good indictments again from the normal
investigation no I mean like Trump isn't
a Russian spy he wasn't working with the
Soviets oh probably like though like
they nothing was born of those things
you know I mean I feel like this is just
like they're gonna spin their wheels
Trump's going to fundraise off it he's
going to raise record number amounts of
money there's going to be a mug shot
that will turn into t-shirts people will
get rich off of it Donald Trump will win
the election in 2024 and then we'll not
even talk about this moment later on
does this kind of thing give people the
right to go deeper into his life and
look for things and serve subpoenas and
warrants and things to like look at
emails from 20 years ago does it open up
old I would hope that prosecutors are
being intelligent when it comes to
charging somebody that's going to run
for president it's not even the fact
he's a former president said he's going
to run for president the absolute worst
case scenario for the health of this
country is that Donald Trump gets
indicted charged and convicted of
something that's not really that big of
a deal that somehow inhibits his ability
to run for office because now you've
Justified every single conservative that
thinks that the system is trying to keep
him out using judicial means the left
doesn't even get to feel good because
like let's be honest let's say he goes
to jail for something really stupid like
lying about you know paying off a porn
star like you don't even focus like I
want to him to go down for like the P
tapes for the poop stuff right not for
not for this so uh or BS so uh
yeah no I I hope they're sitting on
something good otherwise I have to
realize that making the entire United
States look like a joke like I I don't
think there's anything going to be
anything there I mean it's been years
they've known about this for years and
they've not done anything so it really
just feels politically expedient and
they just disbanded the grand jury two
days ago or something from today they
announced it was going on break for a
month oh by the way that's so weird
I I have a question for you Stephen if
it's kind of off topic but it's somewhat
on topic like this I'm talking about the
war in Ukraine and the Russian war what
do you think is the solution to ending
this or to the Future well wait wait
hold on hold on first question is how do
you feel about the war in Ukraine uh I'm
happy Ukraine is winning I hope they get
back Crimea Russia
so what do you think would be a solution
to make that happen
um Ukraine winning the war and getting
back Crimea and saying Russia how
would what's Define winning the war
getting back Crimea
having their borders restored to what
they were in 1991 when they broke off
from the Soviet Union and when the
entire world recognized the country as
having the borders that it did that
included the dunbas and included uh
Crimea
oh man well there's a lot of people some
my friends think that same thing what's
what's what's the I suppose
justification for U.S involvement
um justification for U.S involvement is
probably that like the stability of
Europe is potentially at risk that we
are seeing an actor engaged in actions
that haven't happened in decades where
one sovereign state invades another
sovereign state to steal territory from
them
um it's just something that we don't
really see around the world anymore
especially in Europe and I think that
the opposition to that should be led by
the United States I think it's important
for us a leader of the world to do that
would you be in favor of a similar
military response if it came to Taiwan
uh Taiwan and Hong Kong are so much more
complicated and I'm not well versed
enough in the history to know if I would
feel the same for that
um the stability of Southeast Asia and
the region you know what I mean um true
but I think that our responsibility
presence we have and the relationships
we have with southeast Asia I mean we do
good relationships with South Korea and
Japan but it's different than than
Europe but um I would have to read up
way more on Taiwanese history and the
deals that China has carved out with
respect to the autonomy of Taiwan to
know if I would feel the same way about
defending them militarily versus Ukraine
but I feel very strongly about Ukraine
and understand the Ukrainian history and
everything that their borders should be
respected do you think the 100 billion
dollar price tag is Justified
um I I think a really big price tag is
Justified I mean I'm not going to sit
here and argue to know the difference
between like 100 billion versus you know
1 trillion versus 500 billion
um dollars but I think that it is worth
it for the United States to be making
heavy investments into the security of
Europe I think that that position that
we have is like the leader of the
western world and leading those efforts
to predict Ukraine is really important
would you go to Ukraine and fight the
Russians no would you send me could
you send other people's kids there to
fight Russians um U.S troops in Ukraine
fighting Russians is
probably something I would not support
but what about what about Special Forces
doing operations to assist ukrainians
um
don't think so well what about I have to
think a lot like what does Special
Forces mean like if we're talking about
like people going over to like train
troops maybe like for instance if we're
sending weapon systems over there and
we're sending troops over there to train
them use this weapon systems that might
be important so that those weapon
systems don't misfire or they're
crashing planes and they did some
they did do it one time yes they did
what about the U.S using uh
reconnaissance measures and surveillance
to provide intelligence to the
ukrainians to then have the ukrainians
use the weapons we provided to say sink
the Russian Flagship in the Black Sea I
think so far I think that's been fair
game I think that a lot of people around
the world share intelligence that's
probably just a given at this point of
sharing intelligence with Ukraine is
probably no difference than than China
or Russia sharing itself with each other
as well what about former U.S military
now veterans fighting on the ground in
Ukraine using U.S intelligence U.S
weapons and U.S funding to assist
ukrainians and say like sinking ships I
think it's it sounds silly but I think
there is a distinction that they are
former U.S military the scary part about
U.S troops and Russian troops shooting
at each other is the potential for
escalation into all of us getting blown
up but if a former U.S military person
gets killed by a Russian troop that's a
Ukrainian soldier that former U.S it is
what it is do you really think Russia is
going like well they're not really a U.S
military so we we're not gonna do
anything about it absolutely I I just I
think there's a massive there's a huge
difference between that guy used to be
um part of the U.S military spreading
Ukraine versus there are armed U.S
troops on the ground there's a whole
escalatory pathway for U.S soldiers in
Ukraine Putin cares absolutely I mean
they just took down one of our drones
whether it was an accident or not they
did a fuel spray on it sure and then we
do dumb like that to each other
sometimes it happens but
um they're having uniformed U.S troops
on the ground Ukraine would be a massive
escalation do you think Russia is going
to allow Ukraine to win
is Russia going to allow Ukraine to win
um well I mean they've allowed them to
get as far as they have so far but now
they're positioning nukes north of
Ukraine and Belarus um I Heard the the
Strategic nuclear weapons being moved
into Belarus
um I don't know why I don't know if
that's posturing the UK is deploying you
depleted uranium tank Busters which are
radioactive
Russia responded by saying we warned you
that if you use depleted uranium that's
nuclear escalation and now they're
moving nukes sure but they've been
they've been talking about nuclear
escalation for like two but then they
did it and now Russia is sending nukes
into the region sure they into Belarus
yeah but like are they actually going to
start using I don't think Russia is
going to I don't think so I don't know
where she's going to use the mistake
people make is they assume nuke means
you know 100 Megaton ICBM doesn't happen
even strategic nuclear weapons I think
would be nuclear artillery unbelievable
depleted uranium is different than
firing nukes no I'm talking about
explosives I'm talking about nuclear
shells I'm talking about I don't think
they're going to be following shelves I
don't think they'd be firing small yield
no Davy crocketts no exotic miniature
nuclear arms I don't think that'll
happen that would be an I don't even
think China I don't think anybody would
support Russia and those types of
actions I disagree
I think that China would support Russia
you think that yes hands down wow I
think the U.S has already lost its
position Brazil was it Brazil and China
just uh announced that they're going to
be trading outside the U.S dollars yeah
that China's brokered a deal between
what Iraq Iran and Saudi Arabia like the
U.S is in such a fractured position
right now that I'm pretty sure China is
going to be like sucks to be United
States I don't think it's about being in
a fractured position I think it's about
I don't think anybody wants to be in a
country where people are shooting
nuclear weapons including China and
everybody else in the world but that's I
think it's going to be in Ukraine this
is what I'm saying the U.S will not uh
this was this was brought up by uh I
think it was it was a new politician he
said if Russia uses lower yield nukes in
Ukraine the West will not respond with
with with with similar nuclear weapons
or greater why would who cares what an
EU politician says though he said uh no
who was this it was it was it was it was
like a U.N guy or something I don't care
who it is if it wasn't the U.S president
no no one is going to risk what
did he say no one's going to rest like
Warsaw for Kiev no one no one if if
Vladimir Putin escalates the conflict in
Ukraine Western forces will not escalate
to the point where they would put their
home countries at risk they will keep
the conflict in Ukraine well of course
but that's Ukraine's not a NATO country
so all we'll do is send stuff to help
but we're not going to be putting troops
there we're not going to be flying
planes over there what they were saying
is that Putin uses nukes in Ukraine the
West will not fire nukes on Russia in
return fire nukes of Russia return I
don't believe so but didn't wasn't
Biden's initial claim that we'd be like
uh we'd be um destroying like their
Fleet in the Black Sea or something if
they were well we took out their
Flagship
um yeah I mean but again I wouldn't I
wouldn't look to a U.N or an EU
politician to speak on behalf of the US
military or what the U.S is willing to
do because at the end of the day that's
really all that matters right I agree
with your principle the country
shouldn't be invading and colonizing
territory but then I look at what the US
did the last 20 years in Iraq we haven't
done anything even remotely similar
um we didn't take it they're not on our
border we have a puppet state in Iraq we
have corporations set up Iraq holds
their own elections they over Iraq is
its own country we didn't take any
Terror story from them we didn't declare
any of this like this is now part of the
United States it's a totally different
scenario from what's happening in
Ukraine Russia we removed the bath party
from Power which caused Isis to appear
you know but I mean you could say it's
it's legit but it's the puppet state I'm
not saying it's legit but it I don't
think they call it a puppet state I
don't think it's fair they hold their
own elections it's they are their own
country we might like it we did remove
Saddam Hussein we did ban the bath party
from reforming that is true but we
didn't take Terror we didn't come in and
say like we're gonna carve off this part
as like new Connecticut right it's part
of the United States now that's an
insane thing to do yeah that's an insane
thing to do we have we haven't done that
Russia went into
um Ukraine and they took territory this
is Russia now that hasn't happened in so
long it's that's a it's an unprecedented
action in this age post 91 both Soviet
Union that's insane yeah I think of it
as like after the Soviet Union broke up
the oligarchs split it all up and they
took away the warm water port from
Russia because they didn't want to be a
global hegemon they were like no we're
going to give Sebastopol to Ukraine now
Russia is landlocked and they can have
their other and it'd be like in the U.S
if they took the west coast and took a
long strip down the west coast of the
U.S and gave it to Canada and we had no
Pacific access that at some point the US
would be like this is insane and we're
going to invade and take Pacific access
and that's where I see the Russians
coming from well but wow they they
recognized the Border that's the country
you might not like it but
it's just de facto like like it's not
day fat it'd be like what if Canada was
like we really want Alaska this is
it's not even connected to the
us we're gonna take this we can't do
that
they could try
if we didn't have West Coast action I
wish they'd try
and it would give us pretext to seize
Canada we would end up taking Canada and
annexing it into the United States no
more land acknowledge the way we invade
it over through Gaddafi we did that but
we did that with authorization through
um through through NATO and even
through the U.N I'm pretty sure Gaddafi
was so bad I think even China was like
abstain for voting no on that one
um but but again I'm just saying that
here's what I'm trying to say there's
something very unique in particular I'm
not saying that like the because I know
a bunch of people swearing out probably
saying oh he wants Iraq and Afghanistan
I'm not saying those invasions were good
I'm not saying our occupation was good
but I'm saying there's something
fundamentally different from invading a
country and taking territory and saying
This Land is mine now even in Ira even
in Afghanistan where we were for 7 000
years we didn't actually say this is U.S
territory now right there are people
there they ran they did their elections
and other things eventually we left but
like it's not U.S territory whereas that
has to happen with Crimean you know we
almost took Mexico I was watching this
documentary on what was it the
Mexican-American War and then we like
Americans were actually in favor of just
taking it and we won but then who
present at the time I can't remember who
it was Polk or something he was like nah
nah Mexico can stay Mexico the tactic
the liberal economic order has been
using this well we took Texas and stuff
it's corporate colonization they took
out Gaddafi set up the U.S dollar and
all these American corporations like
like Sydney blumenthal's Osprey Global
Solutions Hillary made sure that he got
his defense contract in Libya so they
say oh no we're not we're not taking
that land but it is profiting US
massively because we have it set up as a
corporate sure I mean everything profits
us but I mean that's a fundamentally
different thing again from like taking
the land and being like we're gonna I
would argue that colonizing corporately
overseas is much worse than taking an
argument but it's still way different
it's different yeah it's different than
like this is U.S land that we are now
administering legally and you this is
our land now if you legally say it's
okay to invade and take something over
it doesn't make it okay to invade and
take it over just because you said it
was legal
you guys are going in circles yeah okay
let's jump to uh domestic story we're
going in spirals Tim spiral sorry here
we go forward from The Daily Mail
threats yet yeah NYPD orders full
mobilization plan all uniformed officers
are on standby as extra man power is
deployed to Ring to Ring Of Steel around
Manhattan's DA's office amid fears of
violence after Trump's indictment I
really don't think there's that that New
York City is Maga country enough to the
point that they have to worry about a
bunch of trump supporters showing up the
Manhattan DA's office
into the tunnels for drills next and
then we know what happens we've seen The
Dark Knight Rises oh that's right
and then they're going to release all
the inmates from their jails oh man I've
seen the Warriors yeah she's well I
wonder I wonder what New York would be
like if I don't know 8 000 people coming
to villains were just released all those
coveted patients crawling out of the old
person's homes those Power electric
chairs they live underground yeah so
anyway I find this funny because um let
me see if I have this uh this tweet some
here somewhere where is this I think
people are just like so paranoid they
just don't want to risk it right like
January 6 was such a disaster and and it
was a disaster at like multiple levels
of failing to be ready for what was
going to happen I think for New York
they're probably something like better
safe than sorry because oh my God if
something got repeated where they
weren't ready it's just gonna look so
bad on everybody involved sure we have
this uh we have this video coming out of
Tennessee where a bunch of leftists
stormed the capital and fought with
police
they actually made their way into the
chamber
in what conservatives are calling an
Insurrection so I mean that's basically
it look they're playing with cops and
people are getting arrested
and it happened in Kentucky too they uh
but like this happens all the time I
mean it's funny there were there were
numerous protests by the left where they
actually were banging on the doors of
the Supreme Court who actually went
inside to uh uh the the the
Congressional buildings and shut down
legislative sessions and they were never
considered that big of a deal and even
right now it's like the media is not
covering this like I said big of a deal
to shut down your capital state capitals
I guess don't matter I don't know what
well it matters but just how much does
it matter I mean this is covering it
right that was a video by the media
right yeah someone posted it with Kelsey
Gibbs yeah Kelsey Gibbs posted and then
deleted it Greg price got a copy of it
and reposted it and then maybe she
reposted it again uh it looked like it
really wasn't
I don't think anyone got hurt typically
what we mean when we say like the news
doesn't cover it is that like sure local
Atlas may run the story but is it
getting headline attention is it getting
Prime Time attention is it it didn't
shut down the the authorization of the
new president of the United States which
was what January 6 was they were trying
to like slow or stop the counting of the
votes to get Biden elected or something
like that so it was like a federal
election that was what made that one
such a big deal like the plus it was
high profile and it was kind of voted on
by our president I think it was a big
deal too he did say Donald Trump was
involved in setting it up directly you
know not not a lot not the Bible said
but peacefully marched to listen
apologize just getting the people in the
vicinity he was probably I think it was
when he said for a month so they were
gonna steal our election from us and we
need to fight like like held the keeper
I think it was more of that than the
March peacefully thing but but he said
much peacefully and there was a there
was a there was a permitted rally at the
Capitol okay
how can you go okay we're backing up a
little bit yeah how can you take the one
thing that Biden said on stage one time
as definitive proof that he was TR that
he was actually trying to withhold it
but the news they said he did and Trump
literally said that we didn't fight like
hell he didn't say storm the capital in
those exact words
he said we need to fight like what does
fight mean
substanded the capital you're you're
yeah it's not an argument if Joe Biden
said on stage could you imagine if I
told this guy I did this and everyone
went oh no he literally said he did a
thing and we're like hey if he said he
did that we should investigate Trump
said fight and then later now go March
peacefully it's like well those are
metaphors the left says fight all the
time we don't mean physically we mean
spiritually we mean sure politically
it's followed or that was followed up by
months of saying that like they're gonna
steal the election from you you have to
fight to save your country like you
don't think that that type of rhetoric
can directly lead to people saying like
so our election is being stolen like
Trump said it was being stolen and we
need to fight like go to the Capitol and
fight to save her country in that line
do you blame trans activists for calling
for fighting when this person went and
shot up a church or a grade school for
the trans shooter yeah I mean they've
been saying it's genocide non-stop over
and over again and they've been saying
get up weapons and you have to fight
yeah but I don't know why I don't know
why that shooter did the shooting do you
so though so the police said there's a
Manifesto and that they did say that the
working theory is related to the
identity of the shooter okay wait wait
wait you said two totally are the police
saying that it was okay so I'm gonna be
very specific yeah wait yeah let's I'd
be curious because I wrote four
different articles I was trying to find
out was anything from this Manifesto
release I know the media is saying they
should release it they will not
understand as the police has not
commented on the material in the
manifestia what do they say about it
specifically the it was uh uh the police
chief I guess he was asked specifically
did the gender identity of the shooter
play a role he says the theory is that
is the case
we're investigating et cetera et cetera
I heard that that's actually what he
said okay I don't know what that means
like because it could mean what you're
saying so let's say that in the
manifesto they're right they're um
they're saying things like I've been
watching a whole bunch of YouTube
commentators like vosh saying that
there's a trans genocide and I need to
go and take action to prevent that then
I would say that's horrible and people
that are saying actually even if
they didn't say that the people that are
saying there's a transgenocide we need
to fight should be held accountable I
think that's a bad thing if you believe
in stochastic terrorism I think that
that's definitely that but if it's
something like where the person is like
oh like I'm trans people in my life
don't accept me I'm gonna go shoot up a
school I think that's meaningfully
different than inspired by rhetoric from
people calling for violence right
so when we see these protests from far
left it's like at the Capitol like in
Kentucky and Tennessee do you think the
storming of those capitals is the fault
of people like vosh saying you've got to
take I don't know well those my
understanding is the storming of those
capitals was for gun reform Kentucky was
trans rights they were they were holding
up trans right signs was it trans right
I thought that was in response to the
shooting sure sure but no no Kentucky
was that they're banning uh I think it
was Kentucky right they're banning it
might have been Kentucky for Tennessee I
think it was for firearms right
Tennessee was Firearms but it overlapped
with that that issue it was primarily a
Firearms protest can so let's just say
Kentucky the starting of the capital
there where they're in the gallery and
they're being arrested and they're
holding up trans signs do you think this
the the suspense of that the the the the
the the inhibition of that legislative
session and the storming of that capital
is the result is somebody is if
somebody's activist saying take up arms
and go fight sure if somebody's storming
buildings I think they should be held
legally accountable they're trying
passing they absolutely should be and I
think that people that are using
alarmistrator to get people to go and
fight whether that's Donald Trump or
whether those farther people on YouTube
um
you got to be careful Hassan does it but
he says only in video games well you
unless it's an imminent call like vague
calls like hey go do this thing that's
not illegal that's protective First
Amendment but if you say on this day at
this time do this thing then that's an
imminent threat I understand that's
illegal under the First Amendment the
issue that I have is a general alignment
where there's a lot of people saying
that there's a trans genocide incoming
so buy firearms that feels a little bit
like great replacement rhetoric except
on the left instead of the right to me
where people on the right sometimes will
say things like immigrants are invading
they're taking everything you need to
buy fires to protect yourself from
spooky immigrants that are replacing
white people that feel similar to people
saying there's a trans genocide by
firearms because Republicans are going
to take your rights away that that type
of like any type of rhetoric that is
basically stating that like your life is
on the line by a gun in my opinion is
like very very unhealthy for the state
of the country I agree I don't like the
metaphor fight for your rights it's been
around my entire life you gotta fight
for your rights in the United States
they literally did 250 years ago sure
um and throughout the ages they have had
to do that there's different they have
done it literally with weapons and so
the idea that we need to we're we got
into a fight yesterday Oh you mean we
are arguing that's not a real like what
does fight even mean yeah Elizabeth come
on come on well I mean that's what we're
talking about the word fighting like if
you say go fight for your right are you
really encouraging violence okay fine
but like typically every political
organization says fight for your rights
and they are not implying physical
violence I am relying a struggle against
a political machine to encourage people
to vote and to to get in politicians and
get policy in place so if someone's on a
heavy dose of psychoactives and they
hear that and they go fight physically
you've got to put it on the person you
got to blame the person the thought not
the person
I think we have to have like a more
holistic intelligent view of this what I
would say is you have to look at the
totality of rhetoric and you've got to
ask where does it lead if somebody is
saying like listen
um lawmakers are coming for your rights
you guys need to fight for your rights
okay like we got to do that that's fine
whatever but if somebody's saying like
you are being eliminated from this
country people are trying to genocide
you they're going to use whatever means
possible to take you out you need to get
armed you need to train you need to be
ready for when these people come to town
like that's like okay what the
right exactly yes right you have to look
at the totality of the rhetoric it's not
just like a one statement it's like how
is it being presented what we are seeing
with these posters like trans day of
Vengeance it was like they had pictures
of guns on it they're it's being
accompanied by posters that say take up
your arms no one is coming to save you
and videos of these activists saying
quite literally to beat people did you
see that one they got like a club made
of a curtain rod and they're like beat
them beat them hurt them although I'd
say we have to be really careful about
because on how big some things like for
some of these trans organizations that
people are obsessing over the the trans
day of Vengeance and then there was
another one like the trans
um resistance something Network or
whatever trans radical activist Network
yeah like I don't even know if these
things exist
um like I see a lot of like I know Fox
News I think I had a few thousand
followers yeah had like well on Twitter
like that but they're the ones
organizing the the event in DC tomorrow
yeah but I'm curious how many people are
going to even show up to that because I
looked at that page and it's like a
WordPress page with like two links but
that's what it always is and the Twitter
page has like 300 followers and no names
attached you'll get a few hundred people
to show up I bet it's a Russian up oh
yeah Russia I mean honestly uh I would
not be surprised if it was Russia or
China or both oh wait did they cancel it
oh apparently they canceled the April
first thing
April 4th breaking news brought to you
on the Tim
cast podcast what was the April first
thing the trans day adventure oh they
canceled it what a horrible name I know
where did you get that from where was
that news
oh that's good they did the right thing
I think that was definitely this is a
violent call so I think that was the
right move
the organization says this action is not
happening due to Credible threat to life
and safety oh wow I think fight I think
fight for your rights okay Vengeance
starts to get a little bit weird though
I don't like the word Revenge because
can you have peaceful Revenge I guess
you can watching someone fail is like a
form of Revenge if you're like me not
doing it I would say that's an
unconventional use of the word though
yeah
Vengeance that implies past wrongdoing I
do think it's absolutely insane that
after what happened on Monday the
media's response to this was was very
very much like oh the poor trans
Community whereas they typically don't
do that for any other mass shooting they
don't know
it's usually like white dudes like yeah
but when they're like poor white people
no I mean like even the other trans
Shooters right with like Aberdeen
Colorado Springs Denver they didn't come
out and say the same thing it's like
this one they did yeah but I think for
the I think for this one there's a
pretty big deal about it being a trans
person which I don't think it was
necessarily made as big a deal for the
for the past one so and then I think
that the temperature is up really high
right now
because apparently Republicans have
nothing else to talk about but trans
people so we're like all focused and
fixated on trans people right now so
when a shooting happens with it I don't
think it's Republicans I think it's both
Republicans and Democrats Republicans
are obsessed with trans people right now
but Democrats are you know putting books
like genderqueer in schools or I should
say schools are putting those in place
Loudoun County we saw we saw a
republican get elected in Virginia
primarily because of what happened in
London County which is literally two
seconds you get in the car drive 20
seconds you're in Loudon and it's
because these schools they had sexual
assaults they had these books depicting
graphic things for kids and then when
parents wanted something done about it
Democrats called them bigots and ignored
the problem so they turned to
Republicans Republicans embraced it yeah
but isn't this like what our school
boards are for like don't you go to your
school meetings you say we don't want
this here and then you talk to the super
have you watched those meetings uh some
of them but when the parents go and
present the books they get kicked out or
silenced and told they can't speak about
it
for really for all of them all I didn't
say all of them well because because I I
can imagine it happening at like one or
two minutes I wanted to speak in Loudoun
County they changed the rules so that he
wasn't allowed to so he had to rent a
basement apartment to be able to speak
was Matt Walsh a resident of that County
no and you didn't need to be anyone was
allowed to speak at these meetings about
issues so when they found out a
prominent conservative was coming they
changed the rule to Bar him from coming
so he had to become a resident that was
not a rule normally do you think that
might be fair it is absolutely fair that
someone in California can pay AOC three
thousand dollars to help her win her
campaign it's absolutely fair that in a
Virginia gubernatorial election someone
from uh where does he live Tennessee
comes over and says like here are my
thoughts on this matter and why it's
important to change the rules to borrow
it and I think that's but those are
federal level things that we're talking
about generally not the governor one but
like the AOC one but don't you think it
might be a little bit different like
let's say that you've got like uh
okay outside the federal thing the
Democrat local Democrats raise money out
of state all the time sure I'm saying
that if they have like local money for
attendant meetings if I go to my child's
school to have a conversation about the
curriculum with the teachers and there
are other parents there if I started to
see people show up from like California
or Wyoming we're from Nebraska they
gotta be like what like I don't know why
you guys are here right now that would
make me really completely agree yeah so
if I think it was the case that like it
might have been the case and I don't
know for them well actually I don't know
particularly but it might have been the
case that there wasn't a law in the
books for that because it's just
something that's never come up before
but if it is going to be a thing then I
can understand like yeah you don't need
to be at these meetings this isn't like
your political process this is a very
local level thing well so to to go back
to the main point to put it simply I
suppose Loudoun County was a flash point
where parents were not being listened to
they were protesting I remember we we
went down to Catoctin skate park we saw
parents outside tabling being like when
we go to these meetings they won't
listen to us we need change and that was
a huge rallying cry that gets a
republican elected so Republicans are
looking at this and they're hearing
parents say when the covid lockdown
stuff happened and we heard what these
teachers were telling our kids we were
shocked and when we tried to get these
things changed they resisted there's one
one parent's getting sued by the
teachers
or whatever filed a lawsuit against them
because they asked for records on what's
being what's being taught to their High
feeling if we look I'd be curious to
look at that lawsuit because I feel like
sometimes yeah okay look that one up I'm
curious what they're actually being sued
for
um but the my question would be like
can't you just vote out the
superintendent like this is part of our
local election process it's like if you
don't like the school superintendent
don't we vote on that
I I'm like I'm just trying I'm trying to
imagine what the resistance is and now
what I'm wondering is is there
resistance for a majority of parents
saying something or is it a few
conservatives that are fighting against
this and they're upset that their voice
is being drawn up by the other parents
that don't agree with them that'd be my
question on this
I I think there's like
a big difference between sexual
degeneracy and trans
sexuality well not for conservative
that's the unfortunate thing is that
people are talking about transsexuality
as if it's degenerate and it's not you
waving your unit in front of a child in
a bar is degenerate in my opinion
whether it's at a public park or in a
bar where they say it's okay to do it
sure I kind of Wonder this maybe I'm
being a little bit
um unfair here but I kind of Wonder for
a lot of parents if the covid lockdowns
were the first time that they ever
actually looked at what their kids were
reading in school yep
wait what's going on here and so like
the the impression is that like oh my
God all of this crazy stuff's made the
way to this I was like well no that's
been part of a curriculum for probably
quite a while you just never noticed
because there was a school you know
actually give a where your kid is
reading but that that's just a second
you know but I think that's true there
were a lot of videos where
the kids were on zoom's classrooms and
the parents recorded it being like what
are they telling my kids and then what
happened was when these parents came out
and started complaining about it because
no one knew what was going on and paid
attention they said you're lying it's
not true it's not happening but it is
happening and it is shocking and because
parents didn't pay attention this is why
I think it's become a major political
issue right now sure all right what's
this lawsuit I'm curious I couldn't find
it oh well yeah there was a uh I
would need a few minutes I always this
is something that happens I just because
I always tell people if you hear
something like always look it up oh
here's something like uh like a person
was removed from a meeting just because
they were asking questions and then when
I let it go read the story it's actually
like they were making a ton of noise
they were actually once it was private
property and then they were escorted off
and then they like they weren't even
sure to come like things always get like
twisted like really hard course I'm
always curious when I hear like there's
a lawsuit against somebody like what is
it actually for
um well same thing with a bunch of these
meetings and the reason is
they're um parents is this one for Fox
News they'll try to read like they'll be
like hey we came here to complain about
this book and you refuse to listen so
I'm going to read from this book and
then once they do they go whoa whoa whoa
you can't read that stuff in here that's
graphic and they're like yes but these
are in our schools that's the problem
okay yeah I mean here you go here's one
of the stories from uh a year ago
Georgia parent reading sexual content
from a library at school board meeting
is cut off as inappropriate
don't you find the irony the concerned
parent shot back at the school board
member
so this is why people are concerned I
mean have you seen genderqueer have you
seen that book there's just one book we
had uh Oscar and Omani came in and she
brought like 50 different books with
various critical race Theory racist
ideology as well as gender ideology
stuff that was like really crazy like
this book is really crazy and on Amazon
it's listed as 18 and up only it's got
oh like not all it it's just got aside
from the overt sex acts that are in the
book that should not be accessible to
Children there's a bunch of stuff in
there that kids should not be reading
about just in general what so like what
school is including this are they what
like giving it a signing a library I
think a few of them had his curriculum a
lot of them had it as uh
um in the libraries well a lot okay so
librarian school like two those are two
very different things like if my second
grader can buy this at a Scholastic Book
Fair that's one thing but if this is in
like the library of like a high school I
think it's a bit different like there
are adult sections and libraries at high
schools like I don't know High School
librarian getting attention online for
promoting the genderqueer book to
students
blah blah I don't use Google it uh
Rhonda santis actually put together a
presentation where actually listed out
all the schools that had these books and
the craziest thing was that Nikki freed
who's like the Democrat trying to run
against him
took a screenshot of what he posted and
then wrote posting butt plug porn to own
the libs and it's like yo that is a book
showing a butt plug next to an anus that
they're showing children in grade
schools and that's what the complaint is
about if a even a Democrat gubernatorial
candidate is calling it butt plug porn I
think we got a problem sure I just have
to see I just have to see what we're
talking about like what you just brought
up was that a librarian in a school or
was it just a live high school at high
school librarian oh High School
librarian and what is the book that's
being complained about well I Googled
genderqueer is it that they're like
telling kids at the library to rent the
book or is it a librarian on Twitter
promoting the book she went on Tick Tock
and was telling like all of her students
or whatever like you guys who get this
book or something but it was the book in
the library or was it just a library
making because I feel like these details
are really important right like
no it matters you know like if a
librarian is recommending a book she's
like this is a good book to read yes
they can be found at her school's
library okay gotcha okay just making
sure at least geez yeah so let me let me
pull up the Rhonda Sanders one
because they keep saying he's Banning
books and it's like dude telling kids
you can't have hustler in the library
it's not Banning books you know what I
mean
let me see if uh
I can't play this online so don't pull
this up I can't I can't show you this
for the after hour stream yeah we can do
it there but I don't even know people
are going to want to see it
so
did he I need to see it
you got to give people a reason to come
to the after hour streams okay yeah butt
plugs and books might be it yeah let me
find the video if I search for it on
Twitter oh here we go is this it
Ronda santis addresses book controversy
I have to pull up on Twitter because on
Twitter you have the full thing
while he's looking I
about Hillary's emails you said
something was illegal about those what
was that right here let's uh all right
we'll go back to it later so we won't
show this on the stream because YouTube
will give us a strike if I show this
stuff don't do it but uh
you know
let's jeez yeah Twitter video player
sucks I'm gonna have to reload it well
you already saw that much
I can't see what I'm assuming it was a
butt plug it was it was a butt it was a
butthole
uh Roberto Clemente baseball what is can
you read the tweet for me what does the
Tweet say it says yesterday we exposed
the book ban hoax if news stations could
not show this explicit material on air
why should it be shown in schools oh is
that what it okay so they show
genderqueer there's some overt sex acts
there's uh two little boys engaging in
what some they should not be showing
children then where's the uh
let me see this is it's not playing
audio there's no sound coming out of
this third grade and discrimination in a
way that an individual by virtue of his
or her race color sex or national origin
is inherently racist or oppressive
whether consciously or unconsciously
here are the books parents found in
Florida schools and reported for removal
what was found is shocking Let's uh
we'll make it bigger and then try and
jump in another word
the audio is okay
that those are so big and if none of
this causes you to pause there's another
section where a group of boys masturbate
together and are pressured to ejaculate
into a bottle
a Mountain Dew bottle of all bottles oh
disgusting
are these ideologically driven oh here
we go this is a really bad one in
Matthew Nolan was found in a Broward
County school and contains graphic
depictions of how to masturbate for
males and females while also including
an entire section yeah so that that's
that's what Nikki free was complaining
about that this is not appropriate for
children circling the butthole and
explaining how to use butt plugs and all
that stuff so you know I think I would
need it I would need to I'm curious so
is this on a high school library are
these like in restricted sections or
what is the access to these books like
because now because I thought I thought
before it was like a porn book this
seems like whether we agree disagree it
seems like it's a guide for
um sexual exploration for teenagers
essentially what it looks like butt
plugs go a bit beyond that you know they
do but kids stick a lot of weird things
in their bodies a lot of girls that do a
lot of dumb things yeah we
shouldn't be giving children books
explaining how to use butt plugs
probably not I generally probably agree
right but you know again like I'm
curious like what did you just said
that's just it it's like hey what is the
what is the access though right because
like again if you tell me this is
available to a second grader that's a
lot more than like I'm just saying
that's a lot of different than like this
is a high school book that like you have
to be 18 and older to rent they actually
they actually did say this for anal sex
with an encouragement to use a butt plug
even more startling is the guide on how
to sext for children
encouraging them to send photos that
don't include your face hide your
birthmarks and scars and edit out your
piercings and tattoos books by rupee
core such as homebody milk and honey and
the Sun and her flowers let me let me
jump back there's another container
because here Hillsboro okay here we go
they explain why they were found and how
their kids were accessing them sure
[Music]
what was found with shocking Graphics by
Mike curato was founded Broward Collier
Hillsborough Marion Seminole and Volusia
County Schools
the camp the boys go to in the book has
an island that the book says all right
so they basically just outlined that
it's in schools in Florida yeah I know
I'm just saying like you agree there's a
difference between like this is like in
a high school you've got to be like a
junior older to check out versus this is
in like the grade school library these
are two like pretty different some of
them are in grade schools yes like uh
gender career the reason it got so much
attention is because it was in grade
school specifically I think it was in
like a sixth grade classroom or
something the teacher brought it in I
don't know I we we we cover all the
stuff when it happens sure we have to
pull it up right now but like look yeah
simply put this is what conservatives
have been complaining about they're like
hey you know like in Florida they said
if you're in kindergarten the third
grade you should not have access to the
stuff they should not be teaching it
that's it after that you can do like
whatever parents have a right to know
about it and they said that in fact
teachers are still allowed to talk about
identity and sexual orientation stuff
but not in a classroom setting meaning a
teacher could literally tell a student
one-on-one if they asked hey what's that
picture on your desk well that's my
husband or whatever and oh okay that
wasn't banned what was banned was a
classroom curriculum setting of
educating kids on these issues and only
kindergarten through third grade though
they are now expanding it to I think all
through eighth grade or whatever it is I
think it is important the word children
because if you're 17 and tomorrow's your
birthday you're still a child yeah I
guess it's like the thing that bothers
me is that like conservatives will say
things like we shouldn't teach this to
children and it's like that I don't like
some of these books would be incredibly
inappropriate for like a six-year-old
but for like an 18 year old I don't know
it'd probably be good to know some of
this stuff well um an 18 year old is
totally different yeah I know but 17
years included children so like for
instance like I'll fight over man oh
wait we're not in schools I don't think
schools should have this stuff even for
17 year olds
uh there's a lot of stuff available at a
library I don't know right yeah I I
think like a video explain a book
showing how to use a butt plug is over
the line sure and even if you do think
that stuff is fine sure well I mean
that's part of it right I really
disagree like you're talking about Kink
and kink goes beyond basic sex do you
think that like uh like toys for women
should be discussed in books no
I think instruction manuals should not
be in you know what I mean like I I
that's just I think that the issue the
the issue is that teenagers are engaging
and so there's a lot of especially
conservative parents that like to
pretend that teenagers don't do anything
sexual until they're 18. and that's just
not the case regardless of what they
want to believe especially when they
have these conservatives get
pregnant at 16 17 18. anyway but there's
a lot of people like to pretend that
their kids aren't into anything sexual
blah blah blah um and then when it comes
to children that are starting to explore
and do these things stupid things happen
where people are putting dumb things in
their bodies they end up going to ERS or
worse they don't tell their parents at
all and they have like these hugely
complicated problems probably not the
most common thing in the world but again
I think that for like a 17 and 18 year
old like books on this available at a
school library that's not like assigned
as part of the curriculum
um I think you can argue whether or not
it's a big deal or not there's probably
good arguments about sets but it's way
different than like an eight-year-old
having access but that was part of the
issue the reason it comes up is because
young kids did have access to these
books and that freaked people out sure
if that is the case sure I don't know if
I believe that's the case yet because I
don't know if I see anything but if it
is I agree like we there should be an
age-appropriate conversation around
what's available to Children through
sixth grade like probably should have no
access
Rhonda Santos his administration comes
out and says kindergarten to third grade
none of this stuff the Democrats came
out and lied and said it was don't say
gay despite the fact that the bill
barred from people from also talking
about straight marriage as well the I
believe I call it with that bill was
that after it specified K through three
I want to say in the very next line it
said an age-appropriate up to high
school as well I think there was a vague
interpretation there when I look up the
actual bill itself but I'm almost
positive that it included up through
high school as a vague line after that
k-3 thing I'm almost positive because I
remember that we read the bill on stream
but either way it wasn't a don't say gay
bill you couldn't say straight either no
well you should not say straight I don't
know that was true you couldn't say
straight but I did not specify the word
gay or anything it just said you cannot
talk about orientation or identity which
includes all of it yeah but the problem
is you can generally don't need to talk
about an orientation of a straight
because that's just what you assume
right I think that the the main concern
the legal argument that I heard for the
concern for the quote unquote don't say
gay bill was that that bill created a
private cause of action that any parent
could sue or bring legal action to any
school whatsoever whatever they wanted
to if they felt like one of these things
was being brought up in an appropriate
Manner and that might extend to just
saying that like an author of a poem is
gay you wouldn't necessarily say
somebody straight because that's just
assumed right it's like in a movie if we
see like a husband and a wife kissing
nobody asks a question but when two guys
are kissing it's like well why are they
gay right obviously there's going to be
a bit of a different treatment for gay
relationships versus straight ones
let's go to super chats if you haven't
already would you kindly smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends and become a
member at timcast.com so you can watch
the uncensored portion of the show which
will be live at 10 10 pm over at
timcast.com we'll put up on the front
page and if you're a member you have the
opportunity to submit questions and
actually call into the show and ask
those questions so we will be taking
calls from our Discord Channel but for
now let's uh let's read some of these
super chats Daniel Cohen says isn't
Destiny a girl's name
true where does Destiny come from is it
just like a gamer tag yeah I was like
eight years old I was just oh it was
before the game but yeah yes
unfortunately did the game make you more
popular
um initially it pissed me off because it
kind of messed with my SEO but I think
I'm doing good it's trending on Twitter
right now yeah it always is because the
game is usually trending and then if I
do anything people talk about me too so
it gets mixed up I still get emails
every now and then from people that are
asking me like hey can you reset the
password on my Bungie account and like
yeah it's kind of done all right Freedom
Jeffrey 1776 says hi Tim how do I become
an Elite member you sign up at
timcast.com for the 100 tier and that
makes you an Elite member
and then you get access to the elite
chat room and uh the people hanging out
in the elite chat room are networking
that's the point so uh hopefully though
it once we get our physical location set
up the third floor will be like the
actual Clubhouse and it will be
basically like a hillbilly version of a
social club that people in New York have
so like in New York they have the 50 000
a year clubs like ridiculously expensive
like to Soho house or whatever we're
gonna do the redneck version wait you're
gonna have like an actual place in here
where fans are coming we have purchased
a three-story building in West Virginia
that we are putting on the first floor
coffee shop it's currently in the
planning phase okay second floor is
going to be gaming and hangout and then
the third floor is the private club
which is going to be 100 bucks a month
substantially cheaper than your typical
Social Club so it's like the working
class version of these things so people
can hang out meet each other and
collaborate you know gosh like clubs do
your own Equinox
is that what that is well I mean like in
New York I think the Soho has like 50
000 a year to be a member damn it's
crazy yeah like four thousand something
per month they pay but then like there's
free food there's free drinks you're
hanging out with a bunch of rich people
so you're like I got an idea for a
business and then someone connects you
with someone else that's power right
there
helps people uh start businesses
all right way back says DeSantis put out
a perfect statement in regards to the
Trump indictment he said he won't assist
in the extradition and it's a political
person a prosecution he's won me back
with that statement Trump 2024
descendants 2028. I thought it was fine
um but it's it's kind of like him being
like you know don't count I'm not
involved as a you know so it is what it
is you know I'm not gonna give him a c
minus C minus it's like yeah okay
whatever
all right let's grab some more
Mick Spencer says hey Destiny thank you
for being who you are and always holding
fast to your principles I enjoy seeing
you on efap way back
what's that what's up oh man it's a show
called every frame of painting where
they go over like movies and it takes
like six hours to do a movie and I've
been on a couple of those I think oh
they just break it down scene by scene
yeah frame by frame oh wow yeah
all right Max Reddick says Tim Sam Cedar
seems to think you are afraid to debate
him claiming that you asked him to come
on the show during covid as his excuse
for not coming on would you publicly ask
him to come on the show so the issue
with Sam is uh I've known for a really
long time and I made a tweet where I was
like we typically invite people on the
left to come on the show and then they
just never do they never respond or they
respond once they'll get back to us and
then Hassan and Sam both said I'll
totally do it and so I privately
messaged both of them and said awesome
would be excited to have you especially
Sam because Sam was the first guy to
ever give me a shout out media ever he
said like oh look at these guys Occupy
Wall Street fantastic work and I was
like we'll cover the cost of everything
we'll fly you out and then Sam basically
was just like I'm not going on your show
and then tweeted accusing me of like you
know making it up or something well it
might have been a coveted thing because
he just went on um David's show he
tweeted at me that he was going to come
on the show and then privately was like
oh I'm not coming out there and then I'm
like okay whatever like you said you
would you actually set a date and
everything I told you the date I told
you the time you said yes you agreed and
now when I'm setting this up you're like
flaking out behind the scenes and then
putting putting me on the spot if Sam
wanted to would you host a debate with
him on your show no and uh Hassan yes
Hassan politely messaged me and said hey
look man I know I said I would I feel
kind of something like I feel pretty bad
but like I'm not comfortable flying
right now with kova and I was like
totally understand dude no problem later
on when I asked him again he's like bro
I host my own show and I said you are
totally correct like the idea that I'm
going to ask someone who hosts their own
show to cancel their show to come on my
show
I just totally get it so if I like pal
Kolinski for instance has talked about
coming on the show before but I'm like
whenever you can because I know you do
your own show like I'm like you know
people want to come on the show it's
it's like doing me a favor but the issue
with Sam is that I I believe he is like
he's a grifter like you don't think he
believes what he says I believe I think
I think maybe half of it I think he
doesn't know about a lot of issues and
he says things just for the sake of
shock value he makes a bunch of videos
he's like another thing is like all he
would do is rag on Dave Rubin he's like
one of those guys who makes a bunch of
videos just talking about drama and
people that I'm really not interested
and then the publicly agreeing to come
on the show in good faith like that when
I made a good faith offer and then
privately backtracking and then putting
it on me and now claiming I'm scared
like the whole thing's a bit Tim's
scared to debate me no dude he's just a
low brow grifter bro I'll have you on
anytime you want to come on like here
you are and I think you're you're like
substantially more uh intelligent and
capable of debate than Sam Cedar is
I mean obviously that's true no I'm just
kidding um I think Sam's really smart
guy I mean I can't I can't speak to your
private messages but um yeah I would
hope I don't know I don't know I feel
like Sam is pretty pretty he's pretty
smart compared to mostly people but if I
was scared of anybody in the little
debate I think it would generally be
I'll tell you I'll tell you one of the
personal negative experiences okay but
like still being have on the show was
when I tried to explain to him
deontological versus utilitarian moral
philosophy oh I watched this and he
didn't understand it and so my like how
do you how do you convey an idea to
someone who has who doesn't understand
these Concepts well I went for pop
culture and instead like it was a it was
a bunch of I remember because you said
the villain is usually the utilitarian
guy I remember I watched this stuff I
remember yeah and so my I said when I
think we're talking about universal
healthcare and I said it's utilitarian
versus deontological morality or ethics
right deontological ethics is basically
stating that you cannot take an immoral
action against an individual regardless
of the outcome and utilitarian thinking
is an uh an action against an individual
which is unethical is Justified if it
benefits the greater and Sam was like I
don't know what that means and I'm like
okay how do I debate a guy who doesn't
understand these Concepts well me
thinking like I'm here to convey ideas
in good faith said think about Thanos
versus like Captain America Thanos wants
to wipe out and then his response was to
make a video and all of his fans mocking
me for talking about Marvel but here's a
better one when we released our first
song he ran it through an audio filter
to make it sound bad and then played it
on his show calling it calling it
garbage and lying about it I just saw
like that the dude is just the lowest of
low tier grifters Diddy I feel like I
saw them he ran my songs was he on that
episode because it was the girl and the
other guy uh I don't know I don't
remember if he was on the show Sam
Cedar's show played played the song we
put out and put it through this weird
filter to make it sound like garbage
okay and that song actually did really
well it's the best song we've had so far
charted on Billboard in a bunch of
different categories and then they're
just like oh it's so bad oh man it
sounds like Nickelback and I'm like if
anything it sounds like emo not
Nickelback you know I'll point something
else
Patrick Bet David's uh
very cool I didn't see the whole thing
but they talked about Medicare they
talked about finances and then Sam you
put up a video on your channel that says
it's a picture of you and Pat and it
says Sam Cedar debates rich guy who
hates taxes like you didn't even use his
name dude it's all grifting it's all
thank God like he's a huge podcaster you
should make a big deal out of that
he's grifting well
I don't want to fight at every Point
that's part of the YouTube game people
do that I'm sure if I go through your
channel I'm sure you guys have got like
the crazy thumbnails and titles and
stuff like I think my editor probably
puts up crazy thumbnails like there are
times where I asked me was like why
didn't you have this person's name and
he's like oh like this they don't do
well in the algorithm we're like you
can't put that person over the title
it'll the video up or whatever wait
maybe that's yeah but actually
valuetainment podcast would would
algorithmically be boosted way more than
Rich dude which is very generic sure
possibly when you say what do you mean
by that I'm just curious in the literal
sense I believe that his shtick is to
say things to convince people to watch
as opposed to say things principally
which attract an audience okay so like
me personally yeah there's a bunch of
positions where Mike my opinion has
evolved or changed nobody was like
police we had Michael Mouse on the show
and then you know my position changes
more towards yeah okay maybe the cops
aren't as you know I'm not going to
defend the cops as much as I used to uh
for someone like Sam like his people
whether it was him or otherwise running
my song through an audio filter to make
it sound bad like that's just weird and
dirty and and and there's been other
instances like seriously though
I don't really care to think about the
guy okay but when I publicly said like
bro I would love to have you on the show
here I'm thinking like I've debated them
before I know they were like people got
their Hoots and hollers out of it but it
would be great to have them on the show
and then he pulls this stunt I'm just
like the dude played me and then made it
seem like I'm the one who backed out it
was all a grift to Rally his audience
Hassan didn't do that Hassan outright
told me like I'm not comfortable
traveling during covet sorry bro and I
was like I appreciate it man and that
was the end of it I saw a tweet from
Destiny about a week ago that says I'm
about to I forgive everybody from my
past something like that I'm moving
forward yeah I like it
more of that all right all right let's
read some more Super chats free men Die
free says nobody will tolerate a trump
indictment while Bush Biden Obama roam
free while being guilty of Acts of
treason and war crimes Powder Keg is lit
whether uh I'll say this to you Destiny
whether you agree with them having
committed crimes the sentiment I think
you would agree among the people this
country is probably there right yeah the
sentiment is there but again I think we
have to it's important to ask from a
Judicial point of view like what is the
crime being committed because sometimes
we just really don't like somebody we
want them to be like arrested you know I
agree I think you made a good point
about think about if it was Hillary or
Trump and like switch the positions I
think the greater Point often I talk
about though is the emotional state of
this country can't tolerate something
like this it doesn't matter if it's true
or correct what matters is we know Trump
supporters are going to outright be
alike it's BS it's unjust end of story
maybe but I feel like there is I agree
with you to some extent but I I think
that a country strength is measured by
the veracity of its institutions and
when your judicial institutions start to
bend to the whims of whatever is
politically expedient you might be
creating a more scary world than if you
have to tolerate some tumultuous
short-term period of political unrest I
think that's a really important thing to
consider you're in a really scary area
when judges are thinking like we could
indict this guy but man you know it's
going to be really rough on Fox news for
the next like seven days but that's how
it goes
it's like Chauvin or the Ahmed Aubry
case you know about the Armada case
right I'd imagine you'd be on the right
side of that one um those were the the
guy that got chased down who was jogging
in the neighborhood or whatever well the
the felony burglary suspect who was
fleeing the scene of a crime
that's amazing we're gonna have a way
different this is the one where like did
you watch the trial
um parts of it but this is a long time
ago so the prosecution outright stated
he was a felony burglary suspect if you
if you if you get your news from like
corporate press or whatever I'm not
familiar with the case do you are you um
well then just look into it because I
think I think you'd come out on the
right side I did but they were like
there were so many claims like somebody
claimed that for instance like he didn't
have tennis shoes on he had boots on or
whatever but then I saw pictures of what
it was like no these are not boots right
like that's a lie that's the material so
the issue was the police went door to
door everybody had known that someone
had been committing burglaries a gun had
been stolen from a vehicle the cops
showed the picture of our Ahmed Aubry to
the bunch of the The Neighbors when
Aubry entered a home under construction
and was seen neighbors all called each
other someone witnessed the guy running
down the street and they were like hey
that's the guy the McMichaels got in the
truck and chased after him we're told by
police not to pursue but Pursuit anyway
they were in front of him Aubry had a
guy behind him who was filming the whole
time Arbury ran around the truck and
then grabbed Travis I think it was
Travis Michael's shotgun and they fought
over it it went off into his chest
killing him
I think we can make a whole bunch of
arguments about whether they should have
followed or not followed but the fact
that the dude who simply filmed it is
spending the rest of his life in prison
I think says a lot about the fact that
it was it was totally bunk you know what
I mean
like that guy said I wish I could cut
I hate myself that I'm not familiar
with this case I feel like this is one
of the things I'm going to go home and
look into it and it's going to be
completely different than how you've
said it
I just I can't comment because I don't
know I'm not I'm not coming out here
saying he robbed he stole a lollipop
from a little kid while wearing you know
construction boots and they came to his
jogging I'm giving you like so the
conviction was due to the fact that
under the citizens arrest law there was
a potential interpretation where the
gist of it is if it's a misdemeanor you
had to have witnessed the crime but if
it's a felony you're allowed to make a
citizen's arrest without being a witness
to the crime the issue was it was an old
law that was written in a simplistic way
that had like a comma or something and
the the jury instructions by the judge
was you interpret how you how you see it
the prosecution argued regardless of a
felony or misdemeanor you had to be a
witness and the defense argued no no
there's two different Clauses here if
it's a misdemeanor you need to be a
witness however it's a felony you can
make an arrest the jury decided to take
the prosecution's interpretation and
thus they were convicted so simply put
the left argues he was trespassing no no
he the prosecution outright said he was
a suspect in a felony burglary but
because they did not witness the felony
burglary they had no justification first
when they say he was a witness for a
felony burglary what is that what or
that he was um suspect suspect for
felony burglary what does that mean it
means he had illegally entered a private
residence had he yes he's on camera
doing it okay yeah and so the left said
he's just trespassing he's just no no
like burglary does not mean theft it
means when you illegally enter someone's
property and then so then the story that
you're telling me is these three guys
were just following him two guys the
third guy saw him running on the street
and started filming on his phone okay
completely unrelated to McMichaels he
got charged along with him and is
spending the rest of his life in prison
I'll try to look it up more because I
yeah when I because I'm going to argue
with left many people about writtenhouse
they give me crazy interpretation as
well but that's that's the case but we
were right about writtenhouse
um yeah we're right about right now sure
yeah but that's just a case I'm more
familiar with but um I think I think if
you if you look into the library case
you're gonna be like oh wow yeah like
when the Aubry case what did he enter
there was a house under construction
he's on camera going into the property
and like he looks around and then he
leaves
that's felony burglary now I'm not I'm
not here to argue semantics or morality
I'm saying that's literally under the
law felony burglary which the McMichaels
uses justification so there had been a
string of literal burglaries like okay
let me slow down sure there had been a
string of colloquially defined
burglaries where someone entered
property and took items the the
circumstance in question that he was a
suspect on was he was caught on camera
entering private property looking around
and then leaving that makes him you know
that that if that is proof that he
committed the crime that is felony
burglary we've actually dealt with this
so people need to understand this if you
have property with no fence no barrier
people are allowed to walk on your
property and do whatever they want all
you can do is ask them to leave
if you put up a sign saying no
trespassing
and they walk onto your property they're
now guilty of a slap on the rest
trespassing charge because they've been
given a warning if you take a piece of
thread a tiny piece of thread and wrap
it around your property and someone goes
underneath it they've now committed
felony burglary because they have
bypassed a physical barrier regardless
of what that barrier is so when he
entered the house he had committed a
felony now he wasn't convicted of it I
don't know the point was there were a
string of burglaries and the police were
asking people have you seen this man so
when they saw him running on the street
they were like that's the guy the cops
told us about chased after him called
the police the police said do not pursue
okay hold on So when you say this okay
Jesus Christ it's been so long and I
didn't cover this one closely So when
you say the cops told him that right so
I'm just I'm looking at article from the
Independent the white Father and Son
accused of murdering Ahmed Aubry were
told by police that he wasn't a burglar
days before they chased the black 25
year old and shot up dead in the street
according to prosecutors so it was where
the prosecutors lying there or did the
police specifically say that this guy
was not a burglar I didn't know where
that article is from because if I'm
talking about facts after the case
these are opening statements relating to
begin Friday morning of the trial of the
three white men accused of murdering
black 25 year old Ahmed Arbury the
police went to them and said we're
looking for this man he is a felony
burglary suspect the issue apparently
the prosecutors also shared statements
from the suspects where they admitted
that they did not believe that he'd even
stolen anything apparently Gregory
though that's that's the important
distinction burglary is illegally
entering a premises yeah but were they
chasing but that but they they were
chasing it because they thought that he
had carried out other burglaries exactly
yeah right but but apparently he wasn't
just a jogging right
because he walked into a property
because they thought he was stealing
a gun had gone missing and they
thought he was the guy who did it yeah
there was string of that but then but
then when Gregory McMichael is here
telling investigators I don't think the
guy's actually stolen anything out of
there um for statements relating to see
that it was a video where he enters a
building and then leaves
they believe that that was evidence that
he had been the person who had actually
been stealing things a few weeks prior
to the incident a gun had been stolen
from a vehicle that's the most
pronounced part of the story gotcha so
Mr Aubry three times with a shotgun that
sounds like it went off more than one
you should watch the video okay
when they were fighting over it it's off
camera so so here's the issue okay if
two if two people are holding a gun
they're both in possession of the gun
sure so it's not as simple to say in a
news story that he shot him three times
that's a prosecution yeah but two people
holding a shotgun and fighting over it
and then it goes off three times
probably it went off he was still
holding it and then he then he fired it
semi-auto okay a shotgun you fired a
shotgun before right oh yeah well two
people holding even with Buckshot if you
pull a trigger that shotgun's gonna go
flying so it's really weird if you watch
the video you can see both of their
hands are on and they're shaking it back
and forth
they had tight grips maybe I'll look it
up take into consideration the
statements of the defense and the
prosecution are going to favor their
view of the story of course and the the
ultimate conclusion was based on the
fact that they were performing a
citizen's arrest but because they had
not witnessed a felony in progress they
had no right to perform a citizen's
arrest thus and because the cops told
them explicitly to back off exactly and
that he wasn't a burglary suspect he he
was but the cops the cops apparently the
the prosecutor said that the cops had
made the statement to these people days
earlier that he explicit was not a
burglary suspect do we have the video to
watch
the video of the shooter shotgun yeah
I'm curious oh I mean I'll try and pull
it up but I got to be honest we recently
tried pulling it up it's really hard to
find but let's let's read some questions
but anyway my point is just this not
that it's like the clearest cut case of
self-defense like with Kyle Rittenhouse
sure but it's that this guy's not a
jogger it's not so simple say like three
guys lynched this dude or whatever wait
was he not a jogger do we not think like
come on bro like you think a guy drove
26 miles from his house to jog through a
random Suburban neighborhood
um I don't even know if that's this
reminds me of like when people like did
Rittenhouse go to a whole other state to
defend his property the dude didn't live
there
yeah sure but I don't know where like I
don't know where he lives maybe maybe he
lives in an apartment complex he dressed
muscle truck I don't know I truly don't
know I don't know yeah we'll read some
more Super chats and then we'll we'll
talk more you know with Members Only I
don't want to uh what I got what a guy
Drive 26 miles to walk into a
construction site and walk away I'm not
sure like that's what he apparently did
well but well purportedly was jogging
right so they say he was jogging but
there's video you can watch of him
entering this property and and then the
left was like well he was just looking
around you know it's like come on he's
jogging that decides to go look around
in someone's private property it's just
weird if it's an under construction site
I don't know dude seriously you're
telling me that a shark going up three
times in a guy's chest while he was
fighting over it that's a seriously
question right watch the video I don't
know I want to see the video sorry but
no but like the idea that someone went
jogging that decides to in the middle of
the night jog in the middle of the night
then go into someone's house it just
doesn't seem to make sense construction
site but yeah but but like it's not like
a Barren frame it's a house it's a fully
constructed house and there's like
materials inside they're doing the
interior but whatever okay
all right let's see we got here
um Mike casanelli with big old Super
Chat it just says celebrate the first
Super Chat oh well thank you very much
they started doing that thing where it's
like whenever you super chat for the
first time you get an award or something
on YouTube oh yeah in the little YouTube
chat nice you guys have memberships for
your YouTube yet uh we we had members
only chat but we switched to just
running a Discord because it's better
okay and then let people do the free
chat I mean you can pay for memberships
on YouTube to get a little icons next to
your name if you guys yeah we do we do
have that they have little beanies oh
cute yeah and you get uh bocus and
Roberto Junior emojis gotcha all right
let's see let's grab let's grab some
good ones while we're here
Iggy the incubus says seeing his
Pandora's Box is open can we indict Bush
for lying to America to justify Iraq's
Invasion what about Obama for Abdullahi
um I mean how about we just go for Bush
and the Iraq invasion and all that stuff
should he be arrested for that I'm gonna
break a law I mean is it illegal for the
president to lie to Citizens I don't
know is that a law I'm not sure if
that's a law man protected speech it
should be
like declaring war
all right let's uh
let's grab some super chats
I'm trying I'm trying to I'm trying to
find a good one you know so bear with me
guys
Raymond g Stanley Jr says Tim Libby
listen to you in an article about Biden
saying trans people shape our nation's
Soul no affirming care only only child
sex change and medical mutilation nice
correct words oh hi Destiny
I know I'm always yelling at the post
Millennials for me and they like they
listen to the show and Libby's always
hanging out so it's like they know like
I they know I know that they're they're
gonna listen
but they wrote an article where they
said something like assault rifle and I
was like it's not an assault rifle so
they fixed it and then they called
something gender affirming care and I'm
like just call it a child sex change
all right what do we got
just a lot of people who don't like
Destiny based yeah yeah
uh let's see we got Noob actual say Tim
I appreciate your Insight on the show
you give I'd love to see you guys reach
out to Lucas botkin he has very radical
really traditional two-way views
top-notch American
very interesting
all right
yo uh yeomani gaming says this is
infuriating Destiny is outright wrong
about Trump he never threatened to
withhold Aid Biden did that on camera
look up the Trump call wow is that true
today's the first I've ever heard that
Trump was threatened to withhold it all
so pretty sure that's what he got
impeached for that was that was the news
narrative but to be fair we should
probably just pull up the actual
transcript of the call and then be right
about as to whether it was or wasn't
all right and just uh let's see here's
another one that says Destiny's a liar
yes
all right John Casey says does anyone
believe that Trump can receive a fair
trial in New York let alone in New York
City they want to take this farce to
court fine but they should have to
change it as a neutral to a neutral
venue as possible to as neutral a venue
as possible what does that mean uh it
shouldn't be tried in New York City yeah
but I mean like what would be a neutral
venue for Donald J Trump uh Northern
north northern uh if you go north of New
York City literally 45 minutes you
actually get a 50 50 Zone sure you get a
jurisdiction with a court I'm just
saying that like I'm imagine like
interviewing jurors like do you have a
strong opinion on Donald Trump like it
feels like everybody's going to be
incredibly well no but there's a there's
like if you go 45 minutes north of New
York like not even four of Manhattan if
you go just north of like the Bronx it's
50 50 Republican Democrat so if they ask
people you get people to be like yeah
voted for them sure oh yeah no but I
mean like like typically a jury is
supposed to be unbias it's not supposed
to be six in favor of six against them
it's supposed to right right yeah it's
just gonna be heated yeah there's no way
to get a jury who's gonna be like I
don't know who's
do you know who this man is I do he was
the president do you like him oh boy
that's gonna be scary too because
there's gonna be people are going to
look around and they're going to be
thinking they do like him but they're
not going to say it publicly
William Jones says Tim you need to get
update on your two-way rights you can
use weed and have guns courts gave it
the okay about a month ago
I don't think that's on the uh the forms
right now I don't think it's on the
forums
all right El Rojo Grande says Obama was
sued by the ACLU for that strike and
lost the courts have already decided it
wasn't lawful which can only mean it was
a crime just never charged
hmm wait what is that if they suit him
for that and lost how did they decide it
was unlawful
uh yeah it depends was it was it like a
wrongful death suit like it depends on
what the lawsuit was
but you know like wasn't O.J he he won
the criminal case but lost the civil
case sure and then he wrote a book
called if I did it and then the family
won the rights of the book and then made
the if really really small
and it just says I did it you know that
was funny
all right
David Morton says I disagree with
Destiny on almost everything but he has
my respect for standing up to the online
jihadis Jesus
Russell Miller says Tim and Destiny true
centrists I can agree and disagree with
both of you on different topics but I
recognize legitimacy of your stances
white pill episode
what is that supposed to mean I think it
means that like I'm half Cuban I don't
appreciate that well like people think
you're being honest about your views
white white pilled it just means
optimism okay yeah
means you give them hope for the future
okay yeah that's a good thing it's a
good thing dye your hair blue
yeah a lot of blue hair comments yeah
what brought what made you decide of
diet blue charity oh interesting but now
I like it because it triggers the ever
living hell out of people I'm like the
blue haired guy cuck that everybody
hates so well there you go all right
here's we're gonna do
if you haven't already would you kindly
uh here we go uh ant three four five
says when I worked on a house under
construction someone robbed about three
thousand dollars in tools and materials
that happens a lot it happens a lot all
right if you haven't already would you
oh wait hold on I gotta read one more
speech B says Sam Cedar is obsessed with
Tim half of his thumbnails have Tim pool
in the headline if you're gonna go low
go get Ethan Klein he'll bring Cedar
like he did to Crowder two for one
all right smash the like button
subscribe to the channel become a member
at timcast.com go to timcast.com click
join us sign up join the Discord Server
chat with all the people as the show's
going on and your chat appears on screen
and if you're in the Vib chat meaning
you've been you've been a member for at
least six months or you signed up at the
25 tier you can submit questions and
maybe even get selected to call into the
show and ask questions which we will be
taking tonight so that members only show
will be up in about 10 minutes don't
miss it'll be live on the front page of
timcast.com you can follow the show at
timcast IRL everywhere you can follow me
personally at timcast Destiny do you
want to shout anything out youtube.com
any instagram.com Destiny and
twitter.com the Omni liberal and also
for the show that Tim is doing and me
um I don't think we'll be on the same
one but
festival.minds.com if you want to buy
tickets to the event going on in Austin
by the guys that are working at
minds.com yeah I actually I checked that
URL and it didn't take me to a ticket
page so it might be uh tickets dot
vulcanpresents.com at the moment they
may end up changing that and doing both
oh true yeah Sean good one if you're
listening to me you gave me the wrong
link so suffer so you can go to
tickets.vulcanpresents.com and that's
where you get the tickets April 15th
mindsfest damn
Sean if you want to see Stephen debate
Milo it's going to be happening on April
11th University of Tennessee Knoxville
on Central america.us for tickets for
that and more upcoming events were come
back to Penn State after girl spent Alex
Stein so we'll see what happens next
time people follow you on Twitter oh
what's that honestly that's going to be
interesting because between the two of
you I don't know how anyone's gonna talk
like me and Milo we're gonna moderate it
yeah it's gonna be a little physical
gesticulation yeah show your feelings is
he straight now or he's ridiculous well
no so here's the thing the media lied
about it he says ex-gay he says he is
Milo explained that he is still
attracted to men but he abstains he's
less generate now he's kind of given up
the degeneracy lifestyle and so for that
if he's not having sex at the moment it
doesn't necessarily mean he's straight
or gay he's just celibate he prefers
reformed sodomite yeah he's not straight
what if he had sex with women
but his point was that when he came out
and said this he's still attracted to
men but he's choosing to abstain from
sex altogether oh all together the media
came out and said he's claiming he's
straight now and he never said that are
you really gay if you abstain completely
I don't know I wonder what makes you gay
the act of sex or wanting him all right
all right let's get to the members only
sorry
follow me on the internet anywhere we
also have search dupreya yeah surge.com
let's get to the members only all right
everybody we will see you all over at
timcast.com in about seven or so minutes
thanks for hanging out